just
BR to
off
are we
allow the other
well
get
let me
know members take your
seats they're just going to come in here
as
usual
okay all right thank
you
members take your seats we got a long
day ahead of
us
e
app
hold
I
the
last
f
thank you so much
members take your seats how come to
water chair recognize the member from
Auburn representative Osburn moves at
the house who journ from the session of
February 15 2024 you ready for the
question all those in favor say i thosee
n the eyes happen the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
guest chaplain Reverend Jean Ben East
director of St Paul's Episcopal Church
in
conquer good
morning it is a pleasure for me as the
senior priest of St for church your
neighbor Faith
Community H to join you this morning for
invocation while you're going to start
your
session divine
power you are known by many
name and yet greater than all names
including God of Life god of love God of
community God of
Justice we ask for your blessing for the
community leaders where we live work and
play May the leader of our community
approach their roles with my set of
learning growth and change rather than
focusing only on fixing
problems may they listen to the need of
their constit
and consider the long-term effect of
their
decision always keeping in mind their
responsibility to serve the common good
of all
people please remind them and us that we
are all neighbors and sibling regardless
our race religion gender identity and
socioeconomic stat
May our leaders be inspired to following
the examples said by many prophets
throughout
history may our leader protect and
respect the most vulnerable members of
our society including children the
elderly the poor the angry and the
homeless and the
Immigrant divine
power we ask for your guidance and
support and granting our leaders wisdom
and courage to do what is good right and
TR please help them to
speak when necessary and listen
patiently and respectively when
necessary May
they and we be guide by God who look
over our community with Justice and
love we offer this prayer in the name of
all that is sacred and
holy all that is good right and
true may it be so amen
amen
the chair recognized a member of Milton
representative Claudine Burnham who will
lead us in the pledge of
allegiance to of the United States of
America to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
liy and justice for
all the chair now recognizes new High
School chorus from Milton who will sing
our national
anthem this
way
[Music]
St
flag oh
[Music]
[Applause]
SAR
[Music]
[Applause]
now
the house will attend to request for
leav of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
representative Mills the day important
business Representatives Cole Mason
O'Neal and Pimon the day illness in the
family representative
sandborn these leades of abent shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house
house will attend the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome John
William Bringhurst student at Founders
Academy in Manchester our paage for the
[Applause]
day Mr Speaker please welcome Lisa Nash
k o Shay and Sally Thomas guests of
Representative Morton Gabriella O'Hara
daughter of represent representative
O'Hara Nelly Palmer wife of
Representative Palmer Claire James and
Matthew fideli wife son and Grandson of
Representative fideli they are with us
in the gallery
today W Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
house the house will now attend to the
consent calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on science
technology and energy House Bill 1644
removed by Representatives McGee Kaplan
Corman Wendy Thomas muns nter Noel
Kennedy Bernardi and
cedan the r the bills be removed
representative oborne moves that the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments is printed in that days house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oos nay guys have it the consent
calendar is adopted under rules of the
house from the committee on Commerce and
consumer affairs HB 11198 FN is referred
to committee on Ways and Means Committee
on environment and agriculture hb1 1293
FN and hb1 1565 FN referred to the
committee on Ways and Means and House
Bill 1294 FN is referred to the
committee on finance from the Committee
on Public Works and highways HB
1202 is refer the committee on
finance the house will attend to a
motion of reconsideration the chair
recognizes representative
marter thank you Mr Speaker uh good
morning esteemed
colleagues I rise today in support of
the motion to reconsider HB
154 at after our vote last week I
discovered that HB 154 as amended by the
body on the other side of the wall is a
lot more than a mere housekeeping bill I
learned afterwards that this is actually
a 15-page spring cleaning Bill since it
was not in our regular calendar last
Thursday it is unlikely that many in
this body myself included knew this and
therefore would not have had time to
read and research this massive non-
jerine Amendment
in this unprecedented time of decreasing
voter confidence and an erosion of the
public trust we have an opportunity this
morning to prove that we are actively
working to protect and defend their
rights with each and every vote we cast
we often hear about the ongoing assault
on
Democracy with what we've learned since
last week what better way to demonstrate
to the voters that we will defend their
voice the voters have entrusted us to
perform a thoughtful meaningful
constitutionally responsible analysis of
every piece of
legislation as we know now this is not
what happened last week we owe it to
every one of our constituents to vote
Yes to reconsider no on the subsequent
motion to Concur and then send this to
the committee of conference so some of
the issues we learned of with this
amended language can be addressed and Mr
Speaker I request a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Barry
representative Barry is waving
off MC has requested a roll call vote is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
made
yes
sign
okay
members need to turn on their stations
members need to be in your seats we're
in the voting mode and you need to turn
on your
stations members need to be in your seat
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 154 this is a roll call
vote chair recognize representative
weary for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that as introduced HB 154
sought to amend one RSA using only eight
lines of text but this proved to be too
difficult for the body on the other side
of the wall to handle and so instead
they submitted an amendment containing
493 lines of text changing 30 rsas and
adding even a new
one if I knew that this also um had a
few typos in it that would uh be forced
to go into our rsas and if I knew that
this also had some challenges in the
court because there's a pending case
where RSA 656 colon 40 is mentioned five
times and under our Mason's Rule of
Order it we should not be adjudicating
on it would I vote and press the green
button for
reconsideration thank
you the motion before us is
reconsideration on hb14 this a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
represented
Murphy all
right
represent representative Jamber and Kul
thank
you
all members present have the opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 162 voting nay 201 voting nay the
motion
fails
I will now attend to the regular
calendar okay first things first we have
this amendment the bills open the second
reading open further
amends
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred House Bill 11
one
FN an act relative to the penalty for
false reports of suspected abuse and
neglect made to the division of children
youth and families consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill are to pass with Amendment some
cheerless idell for the committee the
amendment is
0245 printed in house record 7 pages 40
41 chair recognize representative
Spain
this is just on the amendment this is
the amendment okay hold on hold on this
we we have to adopt the committee
Amendment first you said he was going to
speak on it we have to do the committee
Amendment first and then we're going
to there is no debate on the committee
Amendment which is
02458 printed in house record 7 Pages
40- 41 want ready for a question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee amendment is
adopted representative Spain office
floor Amendment
0627 H printed in house record 7 page 41
the chair recognizes representative
plain thank you Mr Speaker members this
bill may look familiar we passed it
through this house last year and the
house position is is that we wanted to
do something to uh decrease the ability
to weaponize Children against uh each
parent and against people so we were
going to put in place a possibility of a
penalty force people who knowingly and
with intent to harm make a false
accusation I'm not going to take up a
lot of time we have a long day you've
seen most of the bill I will tell you
that this floor Amendment adds a word
professional in to a section where we
realized there also was no penalty for a
mandatory professional reporter to not
make a report and I think that if we're
going to hold people to a standard of
not making a false report we also need
to hold those professionals to a
standard of making those reports when
they're mandated and not just leave it
up to their licensing to be able to take
action on them so part of this bill is
to offer a penalty if if a known
professional reporter such as a doctor
or such fails to make a
report and we have narrowed the scope
the only AR argument that came out in
exec session I'm told was uh that it it
everybody's a mandatory reporter so this
would apply to everyone so we narrowed
that scope down to just those
professionals who are mandatory
reporters who have lived and worked
their life knowing that they had to make
reports but we realized there was no
teeth to that so I would ask you to
please support this amendment it adds
the word professional and it takes the
burden off of the majority of people
there's no penalty going on to your
average citizen only those mandatory
reporters if we pass this amendment
thank
you the motion before us is the splain
floor Amendment
0627 H printed in house record 7 page
41 a division has been requested members
take your seats this will be a division
vote on the floor
Amendment
that's
fine okay I just wanted to know if I
should if I
was
clear
e
the motion before us is on the floor
Amendment this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
repr
car
you didn't check in representative
that's why yes or no thank
you all set PA members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
of the
vote 190 voting a 183 voting a the floor
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is a to pass as amended chair
recognize from senth
Gibbon thank you Mr
Speaker is the microphone on thank you
Mr Speaker um like representative
Sweeney said we voted on this last year
and it uh it passed the house but it
didn't pass the Senate uh I personally
think that this is a good bill there are
Bad actors out there that
unfortunately uh do
maliciously uh report to
DCF uh you know essentially making fake
uh claims it's
dcf's job to sort that out and they can
tell based on if there's a pattern of
people who uh make these uh malicious
reports that's for them to sort out it
does not affect
the um I'm sorry I'm saying um a lot it
doesn't affect whether or not someone
can report anonymously and it doesn't
affect mandatory
reporting I think this is a good bill I
think it should
pass that's that's all I have to say we
did it last year we should do it again
thank
you do you I recognize representative
Raymond thank you Mr Speaker when
considering imposing penalties on people
calling dcyf it's important to
understand the current state of child
protection in New Hampshire in order to
make a finding of abuse DCF must show a
preponderance of the evidence that a
child has suffered protracted impairment
from injury that was caused by other
than accidental means in order to have a
finding of neglect DCF must show a
preponderance of the evidence that the
child's health has suffered harm as a
result of lack of supervision or care of
the parents and that the depr
deprivation was not due to financial
means these are difficult standards to
meet if dcyf receives a call that a
child is covered in bruises in different
states of healing and the parent parent
does not have an explanation for the
injuries that is an unfounded
report if a nonc crawling baby has
multiple broken bones but there is some
doubt about how they occurred that is an
unfounded report this
bill assumes that unfounded reports and
false reports are equivalent that is
simply not the case the vast majority of
people who call DCF are genuinely
concerned about children being in danger
that New Hampshire determines that 85%
of reports are unfounded says more about
our thresholds for intervention than
about the motivations of people calling
currently every single adult in New
Hampshire is legally obligated to call
dcyf if they are concerned about a child
we are all mandated reporters under RSA
169c it is in the best interest of
children to continue this practice and
let the experts figure out if there is
sufficient evidence to move forward the
office of the child advocate and several
child welfare agencies testify that they
have concerns that the potential for
criminal charges for calling DCF will
have a chilling impact on people who are
concerned about kids having fewer people
called dcyf is the opposite of what we
need in New Hampshire the office of the
child advocate released their annual
report earlier this month in it they
reported that 29 children under the age
of 17 died in New Hampshire last year 18
of those were
infants two were homicides and one died
as a direct result of
abuse we should be focused on passing
bills that increase safety for our
community's children not those that make
it less likely for children in danger to
get the help they need I urge you to
vote no on otpa so that a more
appropriate motion can be made and I ask
for division
please chair recognize representative
Spain thank you Mr Speaker members I'm
not going to take up a lot of your time
because we have a long day but I do want
to correct a couple of things this bill
makes no equivalency between an
unfounded report and one that would
qualify under this bill for uh possible
charges it specifically says in this
bill that the claim must be made
knowingly false Within intent to harm
that's a high bar there's not any person
who in their heart feels there's abuse
going on and makes a report that would
ever be charged with this in fact DCF
would have to discover a pattern of
false accusations to be able to make
that equivalency and refer it to the
Department of Justice this simply allows
us to put false accusations to DCF the
weaponization of Children and Families
on the same bar as pulling a fire alarm
falsely or making a false police
report it's needed this bill now as
amended applies the criminal penalty for
not reporting only to those professional
reporters not to every single
person those people who have been
trained to spot the signs and have been
told it is your job to report those same
people who are also excluded from ever
having a penalty put on them for a false
accusation because every report they
make is assumed to be made with intent
to actually get help for the child not
intent to harm I ask you to support this
bill we did pass it last year there were
some questions in the Senate that I or
in the other body excuse me that uh I
believe we've straightened out and I
think that we can get this done and make
families not have to suffer the
weaponization of our own departments in
the state thank you
repent of Granger has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
members take your seats this will be a
roll call
vote
clear the motion before a to passes
amender and House Bill
1111 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Greg for parli
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we are all mandated
reporters and if I know that this bill
would only deter those that are
conscientious about reporting and not
those that intend to create harm and if
I know that DCF has a system for
Discerning false and malicious reporting
and if I know that you can already take
civil action against someone who falsely
makes a malicious and frivolous report
against you and if I know that it is in
the best interest to not deter reports
that will protect children would I not
press the red button so that a more
appropriate motion can be
made chair recognize representative D
Sone for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that everything
everybody has set up here misses the
fact that when somebody falsely reports
and it is proven there are no
consequences if I
know that truthful reporting whether
it's found unfounded or not and it is
not a vicious horrible attack on a
family that you're angry
with nothing will happen to you if I
know
finally that of the thousands of calls
that D HHS and DCF
gets there are no assumptions nobody
assumes
anything there are no consequences and
if I know that there are no consequences
for such a heinous act of ripping a
family apart unnecessarily that then I
will vote green to pass this bill and I
hope you join me thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 1 one1
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposer press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
G
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to say the
vote 199 voting aay 179 voting nay
committer report is
adopted and it's on its way to criminal
justice no debate going to
finance
committee on children and family law to
which was referred House Bill 1282 FN
act relative to the duration of child
support considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sentive Lori ball
for the committee the amendment is
04538 printed in house record 7 page 46
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have have it the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the report is committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance another
one committee on children and family law
to which was referred House Bill 1425
FN an act relative to prohib in the
suspension of driver's licenses in child
support enforcement matters having
considered the same report the same the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Heather Raymond for the committee the
motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted chair recognizes a clerk Mr
Speaker pursuant to house rule 47f
representative Terry Roy waves second
committee referral of House Bill 1111 to
the committee on criminal
justice committee on children and family
aw to which was referred House Bill 1564
FN act relative to child support
guidelines having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
the bill ought to pass presentative
Deborah D Simone for the commit
the question before us is a to pass on
1564 FN are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance committee on children and family
law to which was referred House Bill
1573 FN act relative to oversight
of and criteria for residential
placement of children consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation the bill UT to
pass with Amendment Senator Mark Pearson
for the committee the amendment is 0427
H printed in house record 7 page 59
through 63 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it and committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
committee on children and family law to
which was referred House Bill 1595 FN
act relative to adjustment of child
support guidelines based on parenting
time medical support and child care
expenses considered the same report the
same with a recommendation of the bill
ought to pass sen David bigford for the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Gibbons thank you Mr
Speaker I just have to uh pull up my
laptop
here um New Hampshire is one of nine
states that does not provide a formula
adjustment for time sharing um in their
child support guidelines we were there
was a study done in 2004 that gave us a
parenting adjustment guideline and that
was not implemented as of yet uh so 1595
the whole point of it is to implement
those guidelines with some new studies
uh done that accounts for equal
parenting time with the
child
um it also accounts for medical support
and child care expenses for both
parents and and it bases proportional
contributions on the adjusted gross
income so it's the whole point is for it
to be fair for both parents to give more
self-support for be both parents and to
account for the time that the child is
with both
parents um
so there there's just been a lot of
studies done in composing this bill uh
it removes something called a cliff
effect that some studies or some states
that have implemented this model have
noticed in the years that they've
implemented it where eventually you um
it's hard to it's hard to describe
without you seeing the picture
but there's a there's an effect called a
cliff effect where when the parenting
time increases the child support also
increases and then the self- support for
the person uh ends up decreasing this
bill adjusts for that so that we don't
have that
effect this bill also accounts for all
income ratios so it will give the same
model for people that are of low income
of moderate income and of high
income so I would ask for you to support
this Bill thank
you J recognize representative
long thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1595 FN is relevant
to the adjustment of child support
inclusiv of par paren time medical
support and child care expenses there
are several concerns testified to at the
hearing I relay a few that I hope you
will consider while making your vote
one was for a long time the Hampshire
one was from a long time the Hampshire
and mass divorce attorney who warned
that the calculation as it relates to
parenting time would create tension
between parenting time knowing that the
more time spent with my child the less
child support I'll pay often times in
high conflict cases party Drive their
cases as to where they benefit telling
us that courts are picking winners and
losers when in reality it's the children
that are the only winners and losers
section five of the bill States the
court may consider adjusting the
guidelines to include extracurricular
activity among several other factors in
CFL we hear a testimony from residents
that are challenging their final decree
and a common denominator is often the
extra expenses that they pay benefiting
the child or children I'm of the opinion
that in minimizing conflicts these
considerations shall be considered and
and we just passed a uh child support
bill
uh the last couple last couple of votes
we took that uh that shall have uh the
extracurricular activity um has a uh has
an adjustment uh the committee also
received communication from uh nhla the
Hamshire legal assistance in opposition
to the bill staing that it will increase
the ability of domestic abusers
financially control their partners and
will place more victims and Children at
Risk of poverty when fleeing abuse and H
La states that there is no exceptions
provided in this bill for courts to vary
the support calculation where an abuser
is using a system to further abuse a
victim and in closing I'm of the opinion
that it would be difficult in
articulating this House's position if
two related bills were passed thank you
Mr
Speaker J recognize repres
representative
bigford
okay thank you uh Mr
Speaker um first of all the bill that we
did pass just a little while ago takes
care of another end of the spectrum
presid we take care of the zero side of
spectrum where parents have no time or
very little time with their children the
one we just passed takes care of equal
time okay does something there this bill
goes in the middle it fills the Gap that
we have been told to fill for many many
years now I give a little background I
was a member of the child and family law
committee for 12 years starting in
1998 before coming back to it 12 years
later it has been a pleasant surprise
for me to see many families that break
up now agreeing to share significant
amounts of parenting time with the
Court's
approval it rarely happened when I was
vice chair of the child support study
Commission in
2004 just the same we recognized the
value and shared parenting and judge
Toby of J
Durham also on the commission pointed
out the need for a formula that covers
more
situations today shared parenting is
widespread with varying amounts of
parenting
time the guidelines formula presently
only addresses the one parent household
I spoke
to um 2019 there was a Supreme Court
decision called
Anderson which affirmed that there
should be a set of guidelines dealing
with various parenting times and
incomes and it was the legislature's job
to fix the problem so the we've been
warned we've got a serious problem we
got to fix this is the bill that fixes
that HB 1564 addresses 50-50 parenting
time issue but this bill fixes the Gap
as I pointed
out by law the child sport guidelines
must be reviewed every four years with
recommendations about changing the
guidelines to be Equitable the studies
are done by economists social scientists
with Doctorate Degrees
they are far more sophisticated than the
one I was on in 2004 the most recent
review was contracted by the uh Bureau
of Child Support Services with the
University of Colorado in cost tax pays
that report was
$6,350 and if we don't pass this bill
that means we've just ignored all that
money the last one that was done four
years before that said the same thing
that was
$140,000 you will find these reviews on
the Bure of Child Support Services
website waiting for us to put the
recommendations to good use they cost
too much to be
ignored all five reviews for the last 20
years have all recommended New Hampshire
adopt a parenting time formula and that
is what HP 1595 does it adopts a formula
consistent with what California and
Oregon have in place now Oregon leaders
report that the formula has reduced
litigation and that's right in the
report the 2022 study states that New
Hampshire is one of nine states that
does not provide a
formulaic adjustment for time sharing in
the child support
guidelines based on the findings from
the case filed data almost 3/4 74% of
divorce and parenting petitions have a
parenting plan that provides that the
child will be in the physical care of
one of each parent for a significant
amount of
time the majority 61% of these cases
deviate from New Hampshire
guidelines the study
found this 61% deviations rate is too
high New Hampshire is very high in
deviations if if we only went with the
last bill we've heard about we were told
by child support service their attorney
came to our committee and told us we're
going to be going high when we get into
this it's got problems that way but this
will fix
that
um we it is good that we did pass out
the bill because it does have a self
support Reserve uh in it moving it from
120% to
30% uh the the uh Bureau of Child
Support Services attorney did not see
any problems with the bill before us in
fact I don't even remember any
opposition at the public
hearing
um so anyway I I guess that's all I can
tell you someone has a
question no
okay
oh oh thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
1595 long has asked for a division vote
members take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is auto pass on
House Bill 1595 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative Greg for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this body just passed a
more wellth thought out bipartisan bill
that conflicts with this bill and if I
know that the bill already passed by
this body does increase the needed
self-support Reserve in this bill does
not and if I know the bill this bill
does not include a necessary exception
for domestic violence findings and the
monetary weaponization that happens all
too frequently within it and if I know
that this bill will create an even more
conflict within our complicated family
court system would I not press the red
button so that another motion can be
made you I recognize representative mag
leori for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that HB 1595 is a child support
Bill sponsored by Democrats and
Republicans that will Implement
recommendations made by the latest
federally mandated review of our child
support system and if I know the major
recommendation in that latest federally
required review as well as
recommendations from the all five
reviews for the last 20 years have
recommended that New Hampshire needs a
comprehensive formula for parenting time
adjustments and if I know that the
current child support calculator has a
flaw in it that negatively affects the
lower income parent in HB
1595 effectively fixes this and Mr
Speaker if I know the proposed formula
in this bill comes from these
recommendations that 22 other states
have
implemented reflects the preferred
methodology identified by courts
attorneys and parents interviewed for
the review and the correction will bring
the calculation meth methodology in line
with the Benchmark 2019 New Hampshire
Supreme Court case on the issue and Mr
Speaker if I know this gradual change
that will be phased in over several
years without undue burden to our legal
system then Mr Speaker would I press the
green button to support our children who
benefit the most from this legislation
as well as the committee recommendation
of ought to pass thank you the motion
the motion before us is ought to pass on
houseb 1595 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Wendy
Thomas
while members present had opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay the
vote 219 voting yay 162 voting nay
committer report is adopted and it's on
its way to
finance for what reason is the member
rise uh for a motion State motion having
voting on the prevailing side on HB 1111
I move reconsideration and urge the body
to vote
no motion before us is reconsideration
on
1111 are you ready for the
question
all representative Weber has asked for a
division
where
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 1111 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Richard
brown represent
BWI represent V sorry I need a thumb up
or thumb
down I need a thumb up for a thumb down
thank
you all members present had an
opportunity to vote household attendance
stay to the
vote 174 voting nay 27 voting nay
reconsideration fails
members will stay in your seats we got a
vote coming right up right
away majority of committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1633 FNA act
relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis making
Appropriations therefore considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Anita
burrow for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for RM study sen L Walsh for
the minority of the
committee the amendment is 06 8 O
printed in house record 7 Pages 67
through
886 V this is going to be a division
vote it's a division on the amendment so
take your a division on the
amendment know you
didn't
represent chair recognizes
representative wheeler is thank you Mr
Speaker thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise today against
the committee's amendment because it is
a fundamental change to the bill that I
co-sponsored Amendment
6068h takes the bill which would
legalize recreational use and private
sale of cannabis and makes it an agency
store model restricting recreational use
and private sale if this amendment
passes and the bill becomes law as
amended an individual who wants to go
buy cannabis for recreational reasons
will have to go to one of the 15
agencies stores approved by the state
and buy cannabis from a state sanctioned
distributor that is not the free market
nor is it a good way to
legalize big corporate cannabis has
absolutely ruined the industry where it
has been allowed to opening the door for
big multi-state and in some cases
multinational businesses
to swoop in to those 15 stores that we
would have in this bill and buy up those
stores with the big money that they have
for their lobbyists and they have to buy
up those
stores
when all these for that would be forcing
New Hampshire residents to buy
overpriced and under quality product
when they could cross the border on any
side of our state and buy quality
product for AOW lower price with more
variety why would they cross the
border why would they stay and buy
something here in New Hampshire if they
could cross the border so easily to buy
something cheaper better and with more
variety what is the point of legalizing
if people aren't going to be using those
agency stores the monopolization of
these State markets by these large
companies is not a fanciful idea it has
happened where wherever it has been
allowed to even with the guard rails in
place and if someone as I said could buy
it from the black market with more
variety why would they not do that there
are many problems with this bill 6
months to a year in jail for misdemeanor
for public use of marijuana so if you're
just happen to be walking on the street
and a cop sees you and you're smoking a
joint if and you assume that you can
because the bill is legal and then the
cop sees you and picks you up you could
end up with a missed toor charge and in
jail for up to a year we have these
agency stores running differently than
the liquor stores by within the bill
proposing an excise tax on the profit of
these stores leaving the door wide open
for the black market to continue to
flourish this bill does nothing to
address the black market which is
supposed to be the point of
legalization consumers can't legally
grow the plant under this legislation so
what is the point of legalizing a plant
if people can't in their own domicile in
their own castle grow the plant that's
not
legalization folks this bill this
amendment will satisfy the hunger that
we all feel many of us feel for
legalization but it is a baloney
sandwich and will leave us
satisfied but in a few hours we'll be
hungry again because there was no
nutrition there so I ask you folks this
is not the year to legalize in a poor
manner we can come back when the
lobbyists have less control on the other
side of the Wall come together as the
state that we are and pass a free market
solution to legalization that opens the
door for all people to have control over
what they want with this uh drug so
thank you very much Mr Speaker does the
member yield the questions I do member
yields you m
inquire thank you for taking my question
representative and my question is what
evidence do you have that um that
cannabis sold through through this uh
model will be that it
will that it will be not will not be
cheaper and will will not be better than
what's out on the market and that uh the
the black market will do a better job
can you tell me where you got that
evidence better job I don't think I said
the black market would do a better job I
said the black market would have cheaper
cannabis under this model and
representative I appreciate the question
I cannot say the name of the company
I've already made that mistake here on
the house floor in some cases but there
are a number of companies one of them
that has been buying up stores across
the country wherever it is legal they
will buy up those stores and then make
the price of that cannabis
extraordinarily high and that is not
that's monopolization that raises the
prices it's happened in Florida it's
happened in other states and if we
allowed it to happen with the agency
model here where we have a restriction
on only 15 stores then those who has the
money to buy those to become one of
those agencies who has the money to
Lobby to become one of those agencies
those companies so that's why the price
would be high do a member y to further
question thank you this will be my last
question representative um I believe
that you're a sponsor on the bill so my
question is how many of the hearings did
you participate in and communicate with
other people who are on on the
bill I'm
sorry the member needs not answer that's
not that is that question was not that
that question was not appropriate okay
thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes representative
Leon thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues I recognize the challenges
identified by my colleague from Peter B
burrow from this bill but our question
is do we pass something that is makes a
lot of us happy here in a free or Market
situation or do we pass something that
meets the outlines that are actually
laid out for legalization to happen in
New Hampshire and for us to stop being
an island of
prohibition there is an idea that was
floated through a commission over the
summer and favored by some on the other
side of this wall that truly would have
a very tightly controlled Market where
there' be significant opportunity for
multi-state operations to take a very
controlling interest in the process this
bill addresses the requirements by the
man with the pen in a way that allows
the market to open up and to increase
assuming that we see that this is a good
way a good New Hampshire way to bring
about legalization with quality product
at lower
prices on page uh in the middle of page
74 there's actually an outline of the
reasons why we would increase the number
of stores that would be responsive to
the market after this has been launched
and after we know what it looks like to
sell cannabis here in New Hampshire in a
lawful way it also has a 10% charge
which is half that of surrounding states
between a third and a quarter of what it
is in um California where the Black
Market has been um basically
supercharged by doing this I believe
that this is a path that where we can
move forward and then we can figure out
what needs to be done and what needs to
be tweaked in the future to make this
the best model um as my colleague speaks
about the penalty for smoking in public
there there have been some states where
college students have seen that it's
legal and they've gone around blowing
smoke in people's faces that's just
offensive and there needs to be a
penalty from that but we'd be looking at
a third offense after convictions before
you would be facing a misdemeanor charge
you wouldn't be unaware of it there's
ways to be discreet and respectful for
those people who still want to consume
and they don't have to smoke in order to
consume um finally I ask that you
support this amendment if you do support
a past path to legalization I believe
it's a compromise every single person in
a seat here can find a reason to vote
against the amendment and to vote
against the bill but the question is do
we have a net benefit to the state by
passing this and I truly do that's why I
fought this battle and I hope you'll
join me in passing this amendment thank
you the motion before us is on the
amendment
0680 this is a division vote members
take your
seats
the motion before us is a Amendment
0680 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Heath Howard
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh and
thank you fellow representatives for
letting me speak today uh cannabis
legalization should happen in this state
but the committee amendment is makes
this bill worse and if I know that not
only uh that this bill not only keeps
the current misdemeanor charges for
people smoking in public but also
increases the second violation f
if I know that this would create a
state-owned model not bold or large
enough to force out the black market by
imposing an excise tax and limiting the
number of
dispensaries and if I know that this is
not a free market model by forcing out
the opportunity for private businesses
to join the market and if I know that
this bill does not include homow or en
nment of cannabis related charges then I
would encourage you to join me in
pressing the red button so an ought
toass motion can be made thank you J
recognize representative hunt for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know it's been a long time to try
to get a bill that has almost uniform
consensus that is the right answer for
New Hampshire if I know that the state
has already proven that agency soures
are successful we do already have them
for liquor and yes they're very
competitive price-wise if I know that
this was well thought out yes maybe
there are some other pieces that people
would like to see but that can happen in
the future if I know Mr Speaker the time
is now to pass it will I now vote
Yes
the motion before us is the vote on the
amendment
0680 H this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have the opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 263 voting a 16 16 voting a the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass as Amendment
chair recognized representative Tim
kahill
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
members I'm going to agree with my
colleague from Peter burough that now is
not the time to pass marijuana
legislation in the state of New
Hampshire there's more than just
marijuana issues on this
bill there's mental health issues on
this bill there's supporting our law
enforcement on this bill there's
homelessness issues on this bill there's
many reasons that everyone in here could
find to not pass marijuana legislation
in the state of New Hampshire and I'm
sure that my colleagues on this side of
the aisle would agree that education
teaching our kids to stay off drugs is
something that is very important to them
and harm reduction is something that is
important to them this bill does not
meet the level of guide rails that we
were looking for in our commit this
summer I I sat on the commission this
summer and we voted not to proceed with
legislation on the commission this
summer and uh I would urge you to vote
no on the ought to pass
motion CH recognizes representative LLY
wal thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today in opposition to the majority
vote on HB
1633 the proposed legislation of
marijuana will lead New Hampshire down a
horrible and expensive path a 2022
report suggests that marijuana growhouse
emits as much
CO2 as 3.3 million cars on the
road the indoor cultivation of 1
kilogram of marijuana requires 5.2
megawatt hours of electricity and
releases
4.5 me metric tons of carbon dioxide
emissions comparable to that of a
passenger car in one
year marijuana production is nearly four
times more energy intensive than a coal
or oil
production in Massachusetts indoor
cultivation makes up 10% of the state's
industrial electricity
consumption the alliance to save energy
found indoor cannabis cul iation is one
of the most energy intensive Industries
spending an estimated 6 billion on
energy annually that's a hefty electric
bill especially for New Hampshire the
state with the highest electric
electricity costs in the country and
energy consumption issues will only
worsen research estimates that annual
marijuana cultivation electricity demand
will increase by
65% over the next 10 years
Vermont currently has the highest rate
of marijuana use in 12 to 17 year olds
in the
US there's still no field sobriety test
for driving under the influence of
marijuana it priorities prioritizes tax
profits over public health and youth
safety our children are worth more than
tax profits and my friends this is a new
tax and Taxation is
theft I urge you to save New Hampshire
from harmful consequences of this bill
please vote no on the OTP press the red
button so that another and better motion
can be made does the member yield the
questions no no member does not
yield chair recognized representative
Lon
thank you Mr
chairman sorry sorry thank you Mr
Speaker I apologize um I I want to
address some of the concerns raised by
my colleague from Raymond first this
bill was never intended to represent the
views of the commission over the summer
I had expected something else to come
out as that commission was charged with
drafting
legislation however in order to reach
something that would bring us
legalization
we worked hard we worked earnestly in
order to meet as many of those
requirements and as many of those goals
as possible through that process we have
10% of funds that are going to the
substance use prevention and Recovery
treatment fund we have 5% of the funds
going to Children's Behavioral Health we
have a tremendous amount of Education
that is included because it's a lot
better to tell children why they
shouldn't use cannabis while their brain
are developing instead of just saying
it's illegal don't do it in my town of
Derry about 10 years ago there was
somebody talking to the Town Council so
disappointed that she was unable to
convince the school children that it was
just as dangerous to use heroin as it
was to use
cannabis now that's a problem how many
of those children do you think decided
to use heroin since they had tried
cannabis or their friend had and if they
say they're the same why don't I try it
education is more than just saying it's
illegal don't do it and I think that
bringing legalization will help our
children so that we can have a true
honest conversation about where the
risks of cannabis actually
are as far as the police and public
service this bill puts 5% of proceeds to
police and First Responders specifically
for drug recognition
experts there's a lot of people in the
state Who currently use cannabis I
really don't think the number is going
to increase much by passing this
bill with that you'll have a few people
who are rule followers who don't want to
go across state lines who have decided
that because they can buy it in town
they will but I don't really think the
rule followers are the ones that we're
concerned about we're concerned about
those people who are buying it on the
black market and they're buying product
that's contaminated by fentanyl because
of poor product handling we have people
dying from that we also have other
people who are receiving it wherever
they want and driving while
you know that's really hard for people
in towns that don't have drug
recognition experts so passing this bill
and adding that funding is going to be a
net benefit for Public Safety as we have
more trained PE trained officers and
cars who can spot people who are driving
Under the
Influence that is a good reason itself
to pass this bill for people who want to
increase Public
Safety and then as far as the energy use
I hope my colleague will at some point
move towards home cultivation where
people can use natural sunlight and
allow this to work as a plant but I know
the state isn't ready for that yet but
I'd love to work on those conservation
efforts in the
future all in all cannabis is here the
question is whether or not we provide an
outlet for people who are currently
turning to the
streets a way to buy it in the state and
we keep some of the sales here in New
Hampshire liquor store liquor sales here
in the state benefit from people coming
to New Hampshire while cannabis sales in
other states benefit from people leaving
New Hampshire to make these per these
purpose
purchases quite frankly I think it's
high time we legalize marijuana in this
state we do it in a way that actually
can be signed into law and then we move
forward on the details together with
that I ask for your support on this at
to pass at to pass's amended motion and
I hope that we can move forward on this
and actually end our status as an island
of prohibition thank you does member
yield the questions yes member
yields thank you Mr I thank you for
taking my question my question is in the
research that has been done on this
topic and the states that we've compared
to is there has there ever been any
evidence whatsoever that there's been
increases in traffic fatalities or any
fatalities from use
whatsoever uh thank you for the question
when you look at some of the data you
look at reporting biases as well I don't
actually know the traffic data because
quite frankly I I think that whether you
are one state where it's legal around
you or not isn't going to move the
needle that far what we do have to look
at is people do talk about some about
reporting more usage and that's because
if your child has ingested something
you're less afraid to tell the police
tell the police or tell the hospital
what happened so they can treat him
right um I think that more trans Arcy is
good I think that we need to make sure
that everything is handled safely and
this bill has a lot of ways to increase
Public Safety and um I think that by
having more drug recognition experts our
streets will be
safer pres kill has asked for a division
vote members take your
seats not
yet
for
C
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on House
Bill
1633 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Tim kahill for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that legislative
bodies around the country and other
states are currently walking back or
trying to walk back their marijuana
legislation and if I know that every
citizen in New Hampshire deserves to
safely drive down the road knowing that
there isn't someone high on drugs next
to them and if I know that the children
are the
future and if I know we should teach
them well and let them lead the
way then would I now press the red
button so that a proper motion can be
made and I request a division
vote J recognized representative hunt
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mrs Mr Speaker if I
know that no state is
ever totally walked back and made
marijuana illegal again if I know that
Most states wish to do was maybe do what
we're doing which is take baby
steps and most importantly Mr Speaker if
I know that this bill was an agreement
that it took in all the disperate groups
all the disperate issues and was a well
balance compromise with a 17-3 vote will
I now vote Yes
yes the motion before us is majority
committee report of Auto passes amended
on House Bill
1633 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
Okay
so if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay the
vote 239 voting nay 141 voting nay
committee report is
adopted this is going to be sent to
finance and representative Richards had
a conflict of interest did not
participate in the
vote for what purpose does a member rise
I make a motion Mr speaker State your
motion representative McGee and I move
to special order house bill 14 72- FN to
the first order of business after the
lunch break and I will speak to my
motion motion to speci order House Bill
1472 the mo the motion is to special
order House Bill
1472 chair chair recognizes the member
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker
we moved to special order of this bill
because the member who wrote the
calendar report would like to
participate in the debate on that bill
but that member has important family
business that requires him to leave
early this afternoon so we would request
that you support this motion to move
this bill to the first order of business
after lunch thank
you the motion before us is the special
order House Bill
1472 for the first B after lunch are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have
it and the motion
passes majority committee on karmas and
consumer FS to which was referred
houseal Bill 1649 FN relative to
prohibiting certain products with
internationally added p pass consider
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment sen
car spear for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the saying being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate the key
ammin for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 0352 H printed in house
record 7 Pages 87- 90 are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say I I those oppos nay the
eyes have it the amendment is adopted
the motion before us now was a to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I as
oppos nay no the eyes have it committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
majority of the committee on commers and
consumer affairs to which was referred
House Bill 1674 FN act relative to
establishing the New Hampshire legal
tender act and establishing a state
bulion depository consider the same
report the same with a recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study sen Dix daxon for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment the motion before us
is refer for interim study are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay no the eyes have
it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 105 FN relative
establishing a voluntary waiver of the
right to purchase a firearm considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
David Muse for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate s of Terry Roy
for the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker when
this bill came to the committee at first
blush I thought this you know this was a
good idea um to let someone have the
ability to decide what they wanted to do
with their own with their own
rights and then as we heard testimony my
my opinion slowly changed because first
of all the the Second Amendment right as
we know is not granted by the state or
the federal government the Second
Amendment right existed before The
Constitution was ever
drafted what we do know is that this
bill would allow you to put your name on
a registry that future you could not
purchase a
firearm the problem is
that what if someone influences you to
put your name on that what if for
example you are involved with a
psychiatrist and the psychiatrist you've
seen for years and you depend on for
your mental health says to you if you
want to continue seeing me you have to
put your name on this registry you now
have a choice keep your second amendment
rights or lose your doctor what if where
you live they say we don't allow people
who aren't on this list there are a
plethora of ways that someone could be
influenced and coerced into giving up
their god-given Second Amendment
right the part that really really
twisted it for me was the testimony we
heard from the Hampshire Medical
Association from a psychiatrist himself
he said
we like this because it gives a list of
who owns firearms and we have been long
in favor of and support of and wanted
lists of people that own
firearms that scares me and it should
scare you whether you support the Second
Amendment or not any government agency
or or any organization that wants lists
of people for any reason is scary I
would ask you to overturn to pass so
that a better motion can be made thank
you
chair recogniz representative
Muse thank you Mr Speaker before I start
I just want to say that because uh this
bill and my remarks deal with suicide I
want to remind anybody who's listening
in uh on the live stream or in the
gallery who's dealing with a mental
health crisis that help and support are
available here in New Hampshire by
calling the suicide and crisis hotline
at
988 over the summer I met a New
Hampshire mom that lost her only son to
a gun suicide and her reason uh is the
re is the is why I filed her story is
why I filed this bill um and and why I'm
standing before you
today I've had a lot of conversations
with her over the last few months and
what I've learned from those
conversations are three
things the devastating impact that a
tragedy like this can have on the people
that are left
behind the finality of an attempted
attempt an attempted uh suicide by
firearm which has a 90% success
rate and most importantly I've learned
that there are small but significant
changes we can make to our laws to help
people who are at risk for suicide as
well as their
families there are many people who
experience Suicidal Thoughts they can be
veterans police officers the coach of
your kids baseball team your friends
even members of your own
family some are prone to severe
depression others may suffer from severe
bipolar disorder a surprising number
have never even been treated for mental
illness at all because half of the
people who have Suicidal Thoughts are
never actually treated for mental
illness outwardly these people may look
fine and if you ask them most would tell
you that they're fine at least they are
for
now but they also know that when they're
in crisis the catastrophic mood swings
and the overwhelming urge to do
themselves harm will be
back some of them also know that having
a firearm in their lives during one of
these times of Crisis will put them at a
dramatically higher risk of taking their
own life in most parts of the country
including New Hampshire there's no
ability to voluntarily add yourself to
the federal background check system so
you can't purchase a firearm what this
bill would do is change that by
establishing a voluntary Firearms do not
cell list for people who wish to volunt
arily suspend their firearms rights of
their own free will similar bills have
already been passed in Utah Virginia and
Washington
State hb150 authorizes the department of
safety to create administrative
processes needed to establish and manage
the list it also establishes the ground
rules for handling these
applications once a person is on the
list and in the system they will no
longer be able to pass a background
check to be able to purchase any type of
firearm if they change their mind and
they wish to have their ability to
purchase a firearm restored all they
need to do is fill out a simple form to
do that they will not need a signature
from their doctor their lawyer or anyone
else that's because the only person who
can apply to put you on the list or take
you off of the list is
you and on the matter of coercion uh or
the potential for coercion by
psychiatrists and uh and medical people
um I think a lot of us take
medication uh and one of the things that
I always ask my doctor before he puts me
on a medication is are there
Alternatives you know what are the
Alternatives that are available to me um
is this something that I I really need
to do uh is it something that's that's
really essential I I've never actually
had a doctor refus to treat me because I
refuse to take a torvest Statin um and I
and I think that that situation um uh
while there uh there's always the
potential for people to try to influence
your decision I don't think we're in a
situation where we're going to have
medical professionals coercing people uh
to put themselves on this
list I also want to point out to you
that the bill includes a Class B
misdemeanor penalty for anyone who
attempts to to enroll uh or to remove
another person for that from that list
so the bottom line again is the only
person who can put you on the list or
take you off the list is you there's
also an entire section of the bill
devoted to confidentiality in the
protection of
privacy contrary to what you may have
heard this bill doesn't take anybody's
guns away if a person decides to
voluntarily and temporarily suspend
their right to purchase a firearm there
is a process for them to end that
suspension if they decide that's what
they truly
want the bottom line is it's not a
decision about whether or not to own a
firearm it's a personal health care
decision and a case study in empowering
the freedom of choice in a state where
many of us like to loudly Proclaim how
much we treasure personal
Liberty so today we have a choice we can
trust that people who find themselves in
this situation know themselves and know
their vulnerabilities far better than we
do or we can insert ourselves into a
person personal decision that would
simply allow vulnerable people to take
the quickest the deadliest in our state
the most common method of suicide off
the table colleagues please join me in
voting
hb150 ought to pass and Mr Speaker I
asked for a division vote thank
you the motion before is is the majority
committee report of AO pass on 1050 pres
of Granger has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently
seconded when you go
to Second a roll call you have to be in
your seats not walking around the
chamber
[Music]
e
clear
the motion before us members will be in
their
seats the motion before us a majority
committee report of AO pass on House
Bill 1050 this is a roll call
vote chair recognize representative RADS
for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this simple
form that we heard about does not exist
to take your name off of a
list and if I know that the FBI does not
have any obligation to take anybody's
name off of a list regardless of what
the state
says and if I
know there's always free cheese in the
mouse trap Mr Speaker what I now press
no on the out to pass
motion you recognize represent C for a
parliamentary
inquiry house will be in
order thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that this bill is an easy way to
help people who have mental health
crises voluntarily block themselves and
only themselves from buying guns when
they are at their low
and if I know that this bill does not
take anyone's rights away but rather
gives people who suffer from extreme
depression a tool to protect themselves
from themselves and if I know that this
this bill could save lives and uh
prevent suicide by gun and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that you are down with
OTP would I ask you to push the green
button with
me the motion before us is a majority
[Music]
majority committee report of autop pass
on House Bill 1050 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members present had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to say to the
vote 179 voting nay 200 voting nay the
motion of autop pass
fails for what reason does a member rise
I wish to make a motion State your
motion I move inexpedient to legislate
the motion before us now is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 1050 are you
ready for the question a division has
been
requested division this will be a
division
vote
representative swiy has requested a roll
call that is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legisla and House Bill 1050 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present have not the vote
house will attend to stay the
vote 205 voting a 175 voting a the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes speaker for what reason to member
rise I wish to make a motion State your
motion I wish to indefinitely postpone
hp150 that motion is in
order motion before us is indefinitely
postponed House Bill
1050 are you ready for the question
question all
those the division has been
requested I think everybody still should
be in their
seats so the motion before us is in
indefinite postponement on House Bill
1050 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting say ation
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repres
Osborne while members presid have an
opportunity to vote Al will attend the
state of the
vote 204 voting aay 177 voting aay 1050
is inde
postone for what reason is a member rise
Mr Speaker I Rise to request the remarks
be placed in the permanent
journal without objection thank
you jority the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 1186 FN act Rel Rel
ative to firearm purchasers privacy
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Jason jnan for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same be enbl to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Amanda Balden for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0604 printed in house record 7 Pages 43-
44 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted chair recognize
representa
Balden thank you Mr Speaker rewards
programs know the difference between a
gas purchase and a restaurant purchase
because credit card companies apply
codes to Merchants this bill would ban
credit card companies from fact labeling
Firearms Merchants Advocates of this
legislation argue that this bill
prevents big government from meddling in
their second amendment rights however
the only impact this bill has on
government is that it enlists the State
Attorney General to penalize a private
company when they accurately label a
merchant within their own system
additionally advocates for this bill
were unable to address how this
legislation would impact Federal
investigations of terrorist activities
the committee discussed whether
terrorist activities rely on credit
cards and for a 2002 FBI report they do
HP 1186 grows government and puts our
national Safety at risk I ask this body
to vote against the out to pass
recommendations for another motion can
be
made chair recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker um I
have to give all credit to my my my good
friend from C Brook for for discovering
this issue and bringing it forward to us
for
consideration um this Bill what it does
is when you purchase a firearm or a
firearm accessory or ammunition with
your credit card there's a specific code
that goes on that that the bank keeps
and the bank will transfer that at at
the request without warrant to the
Department of Commerce the Department of
Commerce has asked for this information
specifically for this information they
don't care if you buy milk if you buy a
car if you buy a boat they want to know
about your Firearms purchases
why that's none of their
business just this week the state of
Iowa passed the exact same bill and I
believe four or five other states have
passed it in the last year or two now we
heard that well the credit card
companies have paused it for a little
while because certain states are pushing
back we are right we're pushing back
stay out of our business stay out of my
credit card bills stay out of my life
this is the Second Amendment it's none
of the government
business vote against this thank you
does a member yield the
questions no member does not
yield representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
look
the motion before us is autop majority
committee report of autop pass as
amended on House Bill
1186 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Newman for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that when federal
firearms dealers sell a certain number
of firearms to an individual in a
certain number of days consecutive
business days they must report those
sales to
ATF I also know that this bill
unnecessarily prohibits the use of a new
more accurate firearm Merchant category
code that could help ATF prevent gun
violence stemming from cases of straw
purchases gun trafficking and mass
casualty
events and if I and finally if I know
contrary to the claims of the proponents
that this code is not a threat to
individual privacy since it only
indicates the type of merchant it does
not provide any details about the
customer
or or items that were purchased would I
now push the red button to defeat the
otpa motion so a new motion can be
made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
janden for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if if I
know that in
2018 the New Hampshire Constitution was
amended to add a right to privacy if I
know that several states have passed
bills into law that protect the privacy
of firearms
purchasers if I know that the New
Hampshire banking Association and mangor
credit card worked with me on the
amendment that we've passed and lastly
if I know that every New Hampshire
license plate I saw this morning said
the words live fre a do
would I then press the green
button the motion before us is the ma
jority committee report of a passes
amended on House Bill 1186 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
that's
while members presentent had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
to the
vote 203 voting yay 174 voting nay
committee report is
adopted for what reason is
me and it is on its way to
finance
majority the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred house buillt 13 1930 FN act
relative to establishing an emergency
medical services disciplinary review
panel relative to procedures for removal
of records of discipline considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate sen of Terry Roy for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
pass sen of Mark Pro for the minority of
the
committee chair recognizes
representative
pro thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to an
opposition to the
itl uh it had to come out itl because uh
we were working on a bipartisan
amendment that we couldn't quite get out
in time so it had to be a floor amend
Amendment that's in your pocket and we
have worked together to come up with
this amendment so I urge
you to vote against the itl so another
motion can be
made with the amendment thank you chair
recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
committee heard the testimony on the
bill um we like the bill there were
several fatal flaws in the bill which
caused us to vote itl I only wish that
there were a floor amendment that we
could vote on to maybe pass the bill I
don't know but we had to vote
itl the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
13:30 are you ready for the
question sen Weber requested a division
members take this
seats I
think I'll just go right to the
vote
the motion before us a majority
committer report of inexpedient to
legislate on house B 13:30 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Vandy
Castile
all members present had an opportunity
to vote I'll attend to state to the
vote 54 voting yay 320 voting nay the
motion of inexpedient to legislate fails
represent representative Mark
approv uh moves ought to pass in office
floor Amendment
081 18h in your seat
pockets and it's recognized to speak
to his floor
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker and thank
all of you I appreciate your vote except
for 54 of you just saying
so what this bill does is create a uh
disciplinary board similar to what o PLC
has created for all the other boards
right now at division of emergency
medicine uh
EMTs one person makes that decision when
everybody else has a board of three so
we're creating a board of three to
review all the disciplinary action
this bill also or the amendment also
allows people who have been placed on
the disciplinary website
list that after seven years just like
all the other boards your name will be
removed and but that information goes
into your file the other thing that it
does is if you have passed away they can
actually take your name off the list
because you're not coming back for a job
so uh I actually had a friend who passed
away and tried to get their name removed
from the list and they said nope can't
do it there's no provision in law so
we're trying to create that so we can
remove the uh people who have passed as
well and like I said this is a
bipartisan Bill uh so I ask that you all
vote the same way you just did the last
time
thanks the motion before
is proof floor Amendment
081 18h are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I those oppos nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 1330 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay eyes have it 320 to 54 it's and it
is going to finance
the committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 1339 FN an act relative to
Department of Safety firearm background
checks having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment C Jonathan stone for the
committee the amendment is 0
605h printed in house record at 7 Pages
3 through 51 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay guys have
it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is UT to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay
you guys have it and the committee
report is adopted and it is on his way
to
finance
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1128 FN relative to
the definition of a scholarship
Organization for the purposes of
Education tax credit comes to us without
recommendation representative luno moves
ought to pass chair recognizes
representative Alicia
leas
thank you Mr Speaker and I would ask for
a division
vote this bill provides that for
purposes of the education tax credit a
qualifying scholarship organization must
be
incorporated in the state of New
Hampshire currently it's only required
for them to be incorporated or qualified
to do business in this
state the current scholarship ship
organization is registered in the state
and is in good standing which means they
filed all the forms they needed to they
did all the things they needed to and
they didn't do any of the things they
didn't need
to many charitable organizations in this
state are not Incorporated in the
state and that would include the Cancer
Society the Red Cross Planned Parenthood
in fact Planned Parenthood isn't even
Incorporated in the United States it's
an international organization so why are
we singling out one charitable
organization and insisting that they
must be incorporated in the state when
all these other corporations that do
business in the state of New Hampshire
including ones that we give money to are
not Incorporated in the state of New
Hampshire all charitable organizations
should be treated
equally the current scholarship organiz
gation has a parent company that's
Incorporated in New Jersey that
Corporation is very big they have extra
money and consequently they are funding
the operational expenses of the
scholarship
organization which means that the
scholarship organization take can take
every single penny that is donated to
them and give them to students for
scholarships
I would ask you please in order to help
these needy
children please vote against this thank
you very
much chair recogniz representative
[Music]
luno thank you Mr Speaker as everyone
here knows the education Freedom account
program is administered by a third-party
contractor that contractor is
Incorporated in New York and and
administers similar school choice
programs in 19 other
states and in each of these states each
of these states has their own nonprofit
company that receives taxpayer money
from the government manages the student
accounts and processes payments for
educational materials and services
directed by families but not here in New
Hampshire New Hampshire does not have
its own nonprofit manage the day-to-day
transactions as do all of the other
states HB 1128 fixes
this this bill requires the state to
have its own nonprofit Incorporated
right here in New Hampshire and just
like the other states the nonprofit
would file federal tax returns that show
how much money is received from the
state and from charitable
contributions how much is used to fund
efas and how much is retained for
administ ative costs currently only
administrative costs so far totaling
nearly $2 million have been reported
without any explanation about how the
those funds were used or whether those
funds were used to cover costs in other
states there's no record of the more
than $45 million in state funds used for
the New Hampshire EFA program so far no
record on on any charitable tax
filing New Hampshire should have its own
nonprofit to manage the efas in fact it
would be among the largest 1% of
charities in the state the federal
filings would be complete and accurate
and the use of funds to administer the
program for New Hampshire kids would be
clear we can do a lot better than we're
doing right now Granite Staters deserve
clear accurate and transparent Financial
reports for the EFA progr program just
like what other states are doing I
encourage you all to support House Bill
1128 thank you Mr Speaker and I request
a roll
call a motion before us is ought to pass
on House Bill 1128 sen of luno has
requested a roll call is that officially
seconded it is officially seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
e
C
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
1128 this is a roll call
vote chair recognize representative
Noble for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill would make the children's
scholarship fund ineligible to run the
education tax credit program because
they are not Incorporated in this state
but they file annually with the New
Hampshire Secretary of State and
Department of Revenue and continue to be
in good
standing and if I know the reason
they're not Incorporated in this state
is because they can run the program more
efficiently through the parent
organization which saves taxpayer
dollars and allows more money to go to
students in
need and if I know that the
award-winning children's scholarship
fund is the only approved scholarship
organization to run both the education
tax credit and EFA program and that both
programs would effectively be eliminated
by this bill would I now protect
educational opportunities for thousands
of students by pressing the red button
thank you chair recognize representative
Miler for a parliamentary
anory
uh thank you Mr Speaker if I believe
that the organization managing the
education of tracks credits and the
education Freedom account program should
be recognized in the state of New
Hampshire by registering as a non-profit
Corporation if I believe that currently
the education tax credit and the
education Freedom account program is
registered with a New York based
Corporation and that it is difficult
difficult to Access Financial records
from this
entity if I believe that the by
registration by registration as a New
Hampshire Corporation more clarity
accuracy and transparency would result
in the knowledge of how taxpayer dollars
are being spended if I believe this Mr
Speaker would I now press the green
button to support the oop pass motion
thank you Mr Speaker motion for say aut
to pass on House Bill 1128 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Jones
while members presentent had an
opportunity to vote I also tend to stay
to the
vote under 185 voting aay 188 voting nay
the motion of a to pass
fails for what reason does a member make
uh make a motion Mr Speaker stage motion
I move indefinite
postponement
the
motion oh for what reason do a member
rise move to uh lay House Bill 1128 on
the table a higher priority motion
laying on the table is a higher priority
motion so the motion motion before us
will lay House Bill 1128 on the
table we heard division members take
your
seats
clear
the motion is to lay House Bill 1128 on
the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
don'ts motion fails
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to say to the
vote 189 to 189 the motion fails and I
did not
vote now we're back to the question of
inment indefinite
postponement who requested a roll call
uh representative Sweeney requested a
roll roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote members should be in your
seats
clear
the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on a house bill 1128 this a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote else will attend to state of the
vote 191 vot voting a 7 voting a house
bill 1128 is indefinitely
postponed
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1288 FN relative
establishing certain due process rights
for students student organizations and
faculty members fac faing disciplinary
actions by state institutions of Higher
Learning this comes without
recommendation represented beler moves
are to
pass amend we take up Amendment
H printed in house record 7 Pages 46-
47 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those POs nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now Is AO pass as amended chair
recognizes representative
Tanner thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1288 changes certain due
process rights for students student
organizations and faculty members facing
disciplinary actions by state
institutions of Higher
Learning due process
basically occurs when the accused has
the right to publish to a publish notice
of of the charges and explanation of the
evidence an opportunity to tell this
their side of the story and a timely
decision the process and procedures of
disciplinary action in academic and
educational settings are meant to be
flexible plagiarism or complaint of an
unfair grade should not rise to the
level of the same disciplinary procedure
as would assault or
arson at universities colleges and other
educational institutions the student
disciplinary action is a locally
developed process that sets procedures
that are
respectful effective and fair but are
not intended to duplicate a court of
law often the Le levels of the process
go from an informal onet toone on review
or hearing to a formal hearing before
for a disciplinary panel that addresses
the incident determines responsibility
and gives the appropriate
sanctions all parties have the options
of appeals and if they choose a hearing
in a court of
law our state and University and college
systems have well-developed
long-standing set of policies and
disciplinary procedures based on the
clearly stated and published rules and
responsibility in a code of conduct
behavioral policies academic integrity
and sexual
misconduct most of the due process
rights prescribed in this bill are
already happening and are currently in
place at the campuses of our state
universities and
colleges but this bill also proposes a
one-size fits-all process and
requirement that should not be the way
to address the several layers of
violations the severity of the
infraction or the choices of those
involved at our universities and
colleges this bill requires adherence to
specific measures at all levels the
university system suggested this bill
could increase the number of formal
hearings in an academic Year from about
80 to more than
3,000 Not only would this be costly but
it would also slow the process of
resolving disciplinary issues for
students in addition the disciplinary
process processes for most faculty
members are governed by several
different collective bargaining
agreements in which both employee and
employer have agreed on the process for
addressing those disciplinary
concerns Implement implementation of
these rigid requirements in 1288 and its
one-sized fitall for unionized employees
would require extended negotiations with
various bargaining units to change
agreements to meet the letter of the law
1288 is a problem in search of a
solution there was no testimony pointing
to issues that needed to be addressed at
our state's public colleges and
University on the other hand we heard
significant testimony that this
legislation would create unnecessary
cumbersome and costly burdens for the
University and Community College systems
to replace their process requirements to
set up a new procedure to develop
introduce and formulate the various
components required in this bill would
cause confusion and disruption by
creating a parallel program to the one
that's currently in place and almost
duplicates
it in the absence of demonstrated
problems there is no evidence to suggest
that we should or need to change the
approach to disciplinary policy
procedures now the legisl the
legislature has a long history of
leaving process and operation issues
like this to the Board of Trustees and
administrators of our community college
system and our University system rather
than creating detailed management
instructions I urge you to vote no on
this um OTP motion so another motion can
be presented and I ask for a division
vote
please J recognize representative
Lynn thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise in support of the otpa motion on
hp1
1288 this bill establishes certain
minimum due proc process protections
that students student organizations and
faculty members at public uh higher
education institutions must be afforded
before they can be suspended expelled
fired of fired from employment or for
student organizations deprived of any
rights enjoyed by other other student
organizations an issue had come up
during the during the course of this
committee proceedings on this bill is
why does it Focus only on those why not
there are a lot of Staff people that are
employed why doesn't the bill Encompass
them and the answer to that is that as
we've seen around the country those are
generally not the not the people who are
who end up in situations where there're
where their due process rights are
imperiled it's faculty members students
student organizations
those are the ones that um are are often
uh in D in in danger in connection with
procedures that are that are used so
let's take a look for a minute at what
the due process rights are that this
bill spells out and I ask you to think
about them and as you're thinking about
them ask yourself does this sound unfair
is there something wrong with giving
people who are accused of wrongdoing and
facing suspension expulsion firing Etc
of these rights first notice of the
charges second some Advanced disclosure
of the witnesses and evidence to be
presented against the person as well as
any exculpatory evidence that favors the
person third a presumption that the that
the violation did not occur and a
requirement that the violation be proved
by a preponderance of the evidence and I
should note here that that is the
preponderance of the evidence standard
is the Civil standard it's the lowest
burden of proof that we have in uh in
you know in the law so this is not
making this uh these proceedings
analogous to criminal
proceedings the privilege against
self-incrimination would apply there
would be a right to confront and
cross-examine Witnesses a right to
present a defense and call witnesses for
the defense a right to an impartial
hearing officer the the right to have a
lawyer or a non-lawyer uh Advocate be
present at at the at the student or
faculty member's expense this is not
saying you get a right to a government
uh paid for a lawyer uh but you have a
right to have one or or a non- lawyer if
you want to be with to be present with
you a right to a Verbatim record of the
hearing and a right to appeal any
adverse decision to a higher level
College official who was not Direct ly
involved in the earlier stages of the
proceedings the bill allows institutions
to take a mediate action prior to
affording these rights where there is a
threat of imminent harm and to then hold
a hearing later on once the once the
threat has been uh
ameliorated colleges my the prior
speaker indicated that um uh some of the
co some were College administrators that
basically said that came in and said you
know our current practices are just fine
there really is no
problem
interestingly one of the one of the
groups that you would expect would be
here would have been there in the
committee process if there if uh If
there really wasn't any problem is the
union Representatives who represent
faculty members Etc to come in and say
oh this if if we pass this bill there'll
be a big problem but you know what there
were no Union Representatives coming in
and saying this is going to be a problem
and I submit to you that's because they
don't see it as a
problem let me point out to you one
thing that I think is critically
important the prior speaker mentioned
that um in in that most of the
procedures that you that the university
system and the community college system
currently use really comply with this
there's really no difference or very
minor difference if that's really
true then there's no problem because the
bill specifically says that that uh
colleges or universities that have their
own procedures are completely free to
use those as long as they afford the
minimum due process requirements that
are in this bill so they can keep they
can keep doing their uh they can keep
doing what they're doing as long as they
afford the minimum due
process and of course one of the other
things that the bill also says is in
terms of trying to informally resolved
matters um there's no nothing in the
bill and the bill specifically says that
a faculty member or student is free to
wave any of the rights as just as anyone
else would be that are that are afforded
under this as long as they do so
voluntarily and
knowingly let me talk for a moment about
a particular problem that uh that is is
a basis for needing for to for me to
believe that that this bill is
particularly important it's the issue of
potential sexual assault allegations
brought against students or maybe even
faculty members probably more likely
students as you may
know during the abom Obama
Administration there was what was sent
out by the education department
something known as guidance they weren't
regulations that were sort of you know
supposed to have the legal effect of law
they were it was referred to as
guidance um suggesting that that that uh
colleges and universities around the
country were really affording too much
due process uh in these kinds of cases
and that it was Pro it was it would be
okay to uh uh allow some lesser level of
process uh in these in these cases which
did not really afford fairness to the to
the person that was accused used
um that was reversed during the during
the Trump Administration but now is in
the process of being reinstated by the
by the Biden
Administration I have to say that it is
very discouraging to see this
development happening in the current
Administration
um requiring fairness does not in any
way mean that any that anything goes in
these kinds of proceding that in these
kinds of uh due process protections that
are afforded by this by this uh uh
procedure during the during the
committee proceedings on this matter
some an issue was raised about oh well
you know if if a student is allowed to
uh to uh ask questions of of an accuser
uh you know things could get out of
control absolutely not there's nothing
nothing in here that in any way would
would uh would prevent the the the
officer conducting the hearing from from
shutting down something if they're try
if if uh an accused were trying to
harass a victim or something like that
absolutely the hearings officer could
shut it
down I think this is the important thing
that is that I hope you'll consider as
you as you debate on what as you think
about what you what should happen on
this bill our traditions in this country
and really in England going back to the
Magna Carta
have always taken the view that it is
better for 10 guilty persons to escape
punishment than for one innocent person
to be
convicted I hope that all of us all of
us in this room still believe
that I submit respectfully that we
should not allow an exception to this
proud tradition of Justice to take hold
on our college campuses and for this
reason I urge you to press the green
button thank you Mr Speaker and Mr
Speaker I request a roll call
votey has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
you
where
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 1288 this is going
to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Damon for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the university and Community
College systems of New Hampshire already
have wellestablished disciplinary
systems that effectively resolve issues
respecting both parties without
precluding civil or criminal legal
proceedings if needed and if I know this
bill would require renegotiating many
collective bargaining agreements at
considerable time and
expense and more importantly if I know
as a survivor of assault that allowing
the cross-examination of the alleged
perpetrator without the safety of
official court procedur procures is
likely to cause further trauma to
victims and if I know that this bill
discourages victims from seeking help or
reporting assaults would I now press the
red button so a better motion can be
made thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 1288 this
is a roll call vote chair recognizes
representative beler for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker good
morning if I know that this bill
establishes a basic level of due process
if I further know that if colleges
already meet these basic requirements
they must do nothing further but if I
know that it was confirmed to our
committee that sometimes due process is
withheld including the right to cross
examination would I then press the green
button
motion before this is a to pass as
amended inh House Bill 1288 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Jeffrey
Smith represent Julie
Smith repr resent
forz I that I need a thumb not thank
you all members present I Dr to vote Al
attend to State the
vote 192 voting aay 185 voting aay
committee report is adopted and it's
going to
finance committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1517 FN relative
Statewide education property tax and
excess revenue from games of chance it
comes without recommendation pres leas
moves ought to pass chair recognizes
representative
luno thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1517 would reduce the
Statewide education property tax by the
amount of Revenue collected from the
state from what are called games of
chance and only in the amount ount of
that that would exceed $6.6
million so where' that come from that's
the amount collected by the state last
year from games of chance the fiscal
note on the bill says it's unclear
whether revenue from games of chance
would ex would ever exceed $6.6 million
in future years but fair to say it's not
going to put a big dent in the Statewide
education property tax the state reduced
the swept by $100 million a few years
ago and even that didn't make much of a
difference for most taxpayers there are
other bills to take up to reform the
Statewide education property tax and I'd
suggest that we place our attention
there let's vote against the motion of
ought to pass on this bill so that we
can focus on the other bills thank you
and I request a division vote J
recognize representative
Harrington thank you Mr thank you Mr
Speaker um
this bill is simply a bill that's trying
to avoid growing government because we
have new revenues uh I think anybody
who's watched the 6:00 news sees that
woman jumping up and down in the ads all
the time saying how white her gamly
casinos are you've seen the ads for the
Nashua Casino you've seen the one in
Conway that just I just recently been
approved and so this is not talk we're
not talking about the you know having
the these gamblings in the church
basement like we did some years ago
we're talking about thousands of slot
machines are going to be in New
Hampshire we're talking about table
limits going to
$50 and a lot more casinos there's going
to be a lot more revenue from these uh
from this gambling and what the purpose
of this bill is to use that to reduce a
liability that the state already has now
the bill says Statewide property tax but
I'm not an expert on taxes so my goal is
to get this to ways and means and I
would defer to the Judgment maybe as
someone suggested we could use it to pay
down some of the retirement debt which
was which is in I think billions of
dollars and um it would be uh save
everybody money that way the main
purpose is not to expand government
because we're getting new revenues from
gaming if you look to our South in
Connecticut they put in gaming some
years ago with new casinos at one time
there were people lined up three and
four deep just waiting to get a seat at
the blackjack table then the recession
came and all of a sudden those revenues
dropped drastically off but the new
programs they put in hadn't they had to
put in massive tax increases and that's
what I'm trying to avoid with this we
don't want to use this enhanced Revenue
that's going to come in to create new
programs because yeah we're going to
increase the amount of revenue for a
while but eventually gambling is going
to be saturated it's going to level off
and if you re have another recession
which is bound to happen sometime
gambling is a total voluntary spending
it's one of the first things people will
cut out if they are short on money so
I'm just asking you to say let's not use
this new Revenue source to expand
government and if it's as small as the
former speaker just said then what's to
worry there's no new spending in this
and there I mean there's no new
appropriation we're not cutting any
programs we're just saying let's be
prudent about this increased money and
use it to reduce a liability that the
state already has rather than create new
ones thank
you representative luno has requested a
division members take your seats
instead of rolling Harrington requests a
roll call is that sufficiently that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
oh
the motion before us is aut to pass on
House Bill 157 this is a roll call vote
chair recognize representative berer for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I question the notion that
the Statewide property tax should depend
upon the gaming industry as a source of
school
funding and if I know that the Statewide
property tax is currently under scrutiny
with several committees and pending
legislation due to the recent court case
if I know that two years ago we reduced
the swep by $100 million which resulted
in marginal property tax relief across
the
state if I know this Mr Speaker would I
request that the body press the red
button thank you very
much chair recognized representative lad
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know this bill re will reduce
future swep
liability and if I know we hear often my
property taxes are too high however this
bill will raise money without another
new
tax if I know this local this is local
legislation this uh will provide All
Families a welcome tax break which we
all need in this very very difficult
economic IC time would I then press the
green button thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
1517 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members pres had an opportunity to
vote El will attend to stay to the
vote
196 voting a 184 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its ways
to Ways and
Means chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker in a note from the chairman of
Finance I've examined both House Bill
1186 and the amendment I do not find any
spending that my committee can change
therefore pursuant to house rule 47f I
wave off the second committee referral
of HB
okay I recognize representative Edwards
for an
announcement all right so this is
literally a lunchtime announcement I'm
glad I'm next to the door to avoid the
Stampede but uh the New Hampshire
nursing association is right now
prepared to host a free yes some things
are free it's a free lunch for all
legislators uh go talk to the nurses
they uh they keep us well thank
you in the cafeteria sorry major
assumption 15
the house the house will reconvene at
1:15
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
1472 FN relative to debates the house
will be in order members take your
seats relative to debates rebates of
Energy Efficiency funds for electric
vehicles
comes without recommendation Senator MC
Williams moves ought to pass and offers
Amendment
05068 printed in house record 7 Pages 56
through 57 the first debate is on the
amendment chair recognizes
representative
Harrington how the house will be in
order member has a right to be
heard thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
fellow members for allowing me to move
this back so I was able to speak on this
bill I have to say this is a the same
old song we've heard many many times in
the past let's bury a hidden tax and
electric rates and never tell the
electric rate payers about it they won't
know they're paying more for electricity
because of this hidden tax that's going
to use to subsidize electric vehicles
and even if they recognize that their
rates are going up they're just going to
blame the electric elect company it's a
real sweet deal for those people who
believe in Hidden taxes and
non-transparency in government so
where's the money coming from it's
coming from Reggie Reggie's the regional
greenhouse gas initiative that's been in
effect for a few years what it does is
it penalizes everybody who's a carbon
dioxide emitter so they have to pay a
penalty into the electric markets and
then these penalties in the form of uh
coupons are auctioned off and the
results of those auctions minus the
administrative cost and so forth the
return to the States now in New
Hampshire unlike most States almost all
of that money is returned to the rate
payers so the rate payers who paid the
extra money because of the higher
electric wholesale electric rates get
their money back what this bill says is
let's not give them all their money back
let's take some of that money and use it
to spend on subsidies for people to buy
electric
vehicles and you're going to hear
different levels the first time it was
you could make up to $300,000 now you're
going to make make only
$150,000 but the fact remains is the
average income of the person who buys an
EV is over $100,000 a year where the
average mean household income of New
Hampshire is about 78,000 and that means
well over half the people in New
households in New Hampshire couldn't
afford an electric vehicle think about
it if you're making $78,000 are you
going to spend $50,000 on a new car of
course you're not you couldn't afford to
do it so this is sort of a reverse Robin
Hood situation where the people that
have sufficient amount of money to buy
the electric vehicle are going to be
subsidized by the people who
don't it just doesn't make any sense and
remember Federal uh governments already
Federal taxpayers are already
subsidizing EVS to the tune of thousands
of dollars so we simply don't need
another secret tax in our electric bills
if you really believe in what you're
doing and we should subsidize electric
vehicles put it out there in public and
say you're going to tax something where
everybody knows what they're being
charged and what it's going to don't
hide it in electric bills and finally if
EVS are so spectacular and so wonderful
why do we have to bribe people to buy
them why do we have to subsidize them
they should be willing to do it on their
own please vote against this amendment
thank you chair recognized
representative
Ms thank you m thank you Mr Speaker and
uh thank you colleag
um I've always been told that uh you
never want to give a speech after lunch
when everyone's been well fed so we'll
see how that works out today um I rise
in favor of the uh Amendment uh 0506 H
as originally introduced HB
1472 called for the establishment of a
2-year electric vehicle rebate pilot
program during discussions within the
science technology and energy committee
which there was General agreement among
our members that to consider moving
forward we needed more specific program
guidelines and guard rails and this
amendment does that the amendment
clarifies that a total of $3 million
will be allocated to the pilot program
over a two-year period 1.5 million in
year 1 and an additional 1.5 million in
year two it delays the start of the
program until July 1st of 2025 so that
the Department of Revenue Administration
has ample time to set up the program and
the amendment confirms the original
intent of the bill as introduced that
the 1.5 million set aside for the pilot
program each year should come from the
approximately 30 to $40 million provided
to New Hampshire each year from the
regional greenhouse gas initiative which
is paid for by electric power producers
across 10 eastern states extending all
the way down to
Virginia
there are no none of these these these
allowances or fees are collected from
rate
payers the pilot program will offer New
Hampshire residents a one-time rebate of
1,000 for a new or used plug-in hybrid
vehicle and 2,000 for a new or used
battery electric vehicle the vehicle
must be purchased from a licensed New
Hampshire dealership and have a sticker
price of no more than $80,000 for pickup
trucks SUVs and Commercial vans and
50,000 for all other vehicles and I can
tell you from personal experience I
purchased a used plug-in vehicle for
$10,000 to be eligible for the program
New Hampshire residents must be 18 years
of age have a valid New Hampshire
driver's license and have a modified
adjusted gross income as reflected on
their most recent income tax return of
150,000 for married couples filing
jointly
112,500 for heads of household and 75
5,000 for all other file filers these
levels are about half the levels in the
federal program and they were included
in the amendment to maximize the
availability of funding to lower income
individuals according to the investment
of re Reggie proceeds in 20121 report
issued in June of
2023 of the 33 million in Reggie
allowance proceeds New Hampshire
received during 20121 approximately 29.6
million was used to provide direct
electric bill rate relief to New
Hampshire consumers HB 1472 would reduce
that amount by 1.5 million or about 17
cents per Electric customer per month
even after hp1 1472 is implemented we
will continue to return $ 28.1
million of uh per year to uh art uh to
rate payers money that will continue to
help them reduce their monthly electric
bills the 1.5 million for the pilot
program will also continue to benefit
New Hampshire residents it will not
leave the state non-residents will not
be able to participate in the
program it will place New Hampshire
residents on a par with residents of our
surrounding states which all have
similar programs for their state
residents programs that New Hampshire
residents are not able to benefit from
and furthermore the licensed New
Hampshire car dealership ships located
in many of our districts will benefit
from purchases of electric vehicles by
New Hampshire residents who would have
purchased their vehicles in surrounding
states without this incentive program
please join me in voting yes on the
motion to pass this amendment so that we
may vote otpa on hb1
1472 thank you and Mr Speaker I request
a division
vote the motion before us is on the
amendment
H we have a request for a division
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote
e
the motion before us is on the amendment
0506 H this is a division vote chair
recognize representative Bernardi for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this amendment picks
one and a half million from the pockets
of rate payers to give to those buyers
and lessers of
EVS if I know that it subsidizes the
wealthy at the expense of the less well
Todo and if I know one of our tasks is
to reduce electric rates for rate payers
would I push the red button so that a
better motion can be
made
chair recognized represent MC Williams
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this amendment
makes a good bill much better and if I
know that New Hampshire receives between
30 and $40 million annually as our share
of regional greenhouse gas initiative
allowances and these Reggie funds are
not collected from New Hampshire rate
payers if I know that these Reggie funds
are intended to be used by New Hampshire
for strategic energy
purposes and if I further know that 1.5
million per year of that 30 to 40
million in Reggie funds from power
plants will be reallocated from pennies
worth of monthly electric rebates to
fund this electric vehicle rebate pilot
program and if I further know that this
pilot rebate program would keep Reggie
rebate money in New Hampshire as opposed
to directing it to our energy utility
companies and benefit not only those low
and middle-income granite Staters who
wish to purchase an electric vehicle but
also local businesses and if I know that
all of the New England states except for
New Hampshire have a state AV rebate
program would I now press the green
button on the motion to accept this
amendment to make this bill better with
guard rails on this pilot program and
provide low and middle-income New
Hampshire residents the same
opportunities as neighboring states
thank you Mr Speaker motion before us is
amendment 0506 H this is a division vote
if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
to vote house attend state of the
vote 187 voting a 191 voting a the amend
fails the motion is now before us is
ought to pass on House Bill
1472 I'm not sure if this is an order at
this time can I ask for indefinite
postponement indefinite postponement is
that possible at this time it is it is
it is a then i' ask for that please
proper motion so you're making a motion
for IND desperate
postponement I'm sorry I you're making
making a motion for IND indefinite
postponement yes that is correct and I
ask for a
vote the motion before us is indeed
postponement on House Bill
1472 a roll call has been requested by
representative Sweeney is that that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
now he's not going to do it if you
want
all right the motion before us is
indefinite postponement on
1472 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Ms for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
receives representative my
mistake is he's
first my mistake I'm sorry thank you Mr
Mr Speaker recognize representative
Harington for a parliamentary in Mr
Speaker if I know there's only one
source of Reggie funds and that's the
rate payers of the regie states if I
know there's no magical uh source of
money in the sky that every single penny
of Reggie money comes from higher rates
paid by the rate payers and if I know
that this bill would use that rate payer
money instead of re refunding it to the
rate payers who paid it would use it to
subsidize so affluent people could buy
electric vehicles would I please vote
yes now the chair recognize
representative mons for a parliamentary
inir thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
New Hampshire receives approximately 33
million as its share of the regional
greenhouse gas initiative allowances
collected from Power producers across
the 10 eastern states and that 1.5
million of that would be reallocated to
the pilot program envisioned in hp1
1472 and that that 1.5 million would
reduce the direct bill assistance uh to
the average energy consumer in New
Hampshire by about 17 cents per month
per customer and if I know that the
pilot rebate program would keep that
money in New Hampshire and benefit not
only those who wish to purchase an
electric vehicle but also local
businesses and if I know that when HP
1472 is implemented Electric New
Hampshire Electric customers will
continue to receive $28 million per year
in direct electric bill rate relief
would I now press the red button on the
motion to indefinitely postpone this
this bill so that we can proceed to um a
vote of ought to pass and provide this
um valuable program to the citizens of
New Hampshire thank
you motion before us is defly postponed
14 House Bill
1472 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to say to the
vote 188 voting yay 189 voting aay the
motion fails now now we're back to the
original motion of a to pass we have a
de and the chair Rec the chair
recognizes representative
Kennedy chair recognizes representative
Kennedy
thank you Mr
Speaker uh we've gone through some
discussion already because we we were
involved with the amendment but uh I'm
going to
address I'm going to address the the
original
bill as you've heard HB 1472 would
introduce a special New Hampshire
subsidy for the purchase of electric
vehicles in addition to the existing
Federal
subsidies so a little background here
the electric vehicle tax credit was
first introduced as part of the energy
Policy Act of 2005 as a way to
encourage the production and Adoption of
electric
vehicles and established a Federal
income tax credit of up to 3,400 for the
purchase of new hybrid vehicles in 2009
the American recovery and reinvestment
act expanded the credit to include
plug-in electric vehicles and increased
the maximum credit to
$7,500 even if you think promoting EVS
is good
policy how long do we need to keep quote
encouraging
them we have been priming the pump so to
speak for almost 20
years the richest man in the world sells
EVS does he he really deserve more
help in addition a cheating scandal was
uncovered last month by the Texas public
policy
foundation and reported in the Wall
Street
Journal wherein EVS improperly benefit
from an erroneous interpretation by the
US doe of a series of laws promoting
alternative fuel vehicles but clearly
excluding electric vehicles car makers
can arbitrarily multiply the efficiency
of EVS by 6.67
meaning a 2022 Tesla Model Y which tests
at the equivalent of about 65 m per
gallon in a
laboratory is counting counted as having
a compliance value of 430 m per
gallon environmental groups question the
legality of the
rule with current regulations automakers
that don't meet corporate average fuel
economy standards are required to
purchase credits from those whose fleets
exceed them
Tesla alone apparently brought in $554
million from these credits just in 2023
is third
quarter representing a large portion of
their overall net
income ultimately this money comes from
those people who purchase gasoline
powered vehicles in the form of higher
prices clearly the federal
Administration really really wants you
to buy
EVS HB 1472 does not provide a tax
credit but a direct payment of
$2,000 on the purchase of a battery EV
and $1,000 for a plugin hybrid
EV this money we've heard a lot about
this but this money will come from
electricity rate
payers a fairness issue was brought up
in committee it was suggested that one
effect of these programs is to transfer
money from workingclass people to
well-paid
professionals who might find EV is fun
or useful or be a way to demonstrate
their concern for the
environment that argument did carry some
weight with the supporters of the bill
the amendment we were just discussing uh
was the outcome of that discussion where
the upper annual income bounds for
qualification for the program were
lowered from
$300,000 for a married couple to
$150,000 okay all citizens of the US are
currently paying for the Federal
subsidies for
EVS do we want to burden the rap payers
of New Hampshire with an additional
handout for the purchasers of
EVS they are already getting 7500 plus
hidden subsidies like the one I just
talked about do we want the people of
this state to contribute another
$2,000 if you think this is outrageous
or at least uh
unjustified please vote no on OTP so a
different motion can be made thank you
chair recognizes representative MC
Williams thank you Mr
Speaker while the amendment would have
made this a better tailored bill for low
and middle- inome families the
underlying bill is still worth carrying
forward this bill creates a 2-year pilot
using Reggie funds which are intended to
be used to advance energy policy in New
Hampshire this cash on the hoods program
is designed to provide point of sale
electric vehicle rebates to EV buyers
and lores for new and used
vehicles used hybrid and electric
vehicles are rapidly gaining traction as
first vehicles for new teenage drivers
in New Hampshire these are workingclass
families purchasing a local car for
their kid to drive around town the pilot
program offers Granite Staters the same
opportunities as the states around us
including Maine Vermont Massachusetts
Connecticut and Rhode Island that all
offer state-based EV rebate programs
with similar incentives the funding for
this program comes out of the total
funds that are presently slated to be
rebated to individual electric rate
payers during the same period as the
pilot program the reduction of the
average New Hampshire residential
electric consumer Reggie rebate will be
pennies per customer per month for this
two-year pilot and it will meet the
goals of the Reggie funds
program as elected representatives
engaged in crafting policy we are market
makers we have the ability to create
incentives to direct the future of
vehicle purchases in New Hampshire the
goal of this pilot program is to
increase the sales of electric and
hybrid vehicles by New Hampshire
automotive dealers in the granite state
they will also keep a portion of our
Reggie funds in State and reduce the
amount of carbon emitted by new and used
vehicles on our roads this will provide
the same benefit that all other New
England states offer for low and middle
inome families buying new and used
vehicles please join me in voting green
on this electric and hybrid vehicle
rebate pilot program thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
1472 are you ready for the
question a division has been called
who requested the roll
call res of turket re requested a roll
call is that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
clear
motion before us is a to pass on House
Bill 1472 this is going to be a roll
call vote chair recognize representative
VES for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that every
rate payer in New England in the iso New
England territory pays for Reggie in the
cost of their electricity
and then get some of that back via a
Reggie
rebate in New Hampshire it's about 10%
of the
total if I also know that this bill
increases electricity costs in order to
give rebates to EV buyers who mostly
inhabit the ranks of the welltoo
and if I know that increased electricity
costs affect low income citizens more
than all
others and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that EV prices are falling right now and
will soon be comparable to non-ev
Vehicles thus negating the new the need
for any incentives or
rebates would I now press the red button
to say no to this reverse Robin Hood
scheme thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognized representative
mths for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that if I know that
New Hampshire has been and is benefiting
from payments to
Reggie from across the entire Eastern
United
States and if I know that the original
purpose of Reggie was to provide States
like New Hampshire with funds to make
Strate iic investments in our Energy
Future and if I know that the 3 million
to be invested in this program will
accre to the benefit of all New
Hampshire residents and assist in that
transition and if I know that those at
the lower end of the income Spectrum are
the ones in most need of additional
incentives and if I know that the that a
used EV plug-in EV vehicle can be
purchased for as low as
$10,000 which is certainly affordable
for people in the lower income uh
ranges what I now pray would I now press
the green button to authorize this
2-year pilot program thank
you motion before us is aut to pass on
House Bill 1472 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed you press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e represent
pear have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house tend to stay
to the
vote 187 voting a 192 voting a the
motion fails represent
Harington representative Harrington
moves in expedient to
legislate
Mr Speaker I would move to
Table motion's in order motion is in
order the motion before us now is to
table House Bill
1472 a division has been
requested a roll call has been requested
by representative Sweeney it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
e
the motion before us now is to table
House Bill
1472 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
have all members present an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 189 voting aay 191 voting aay the
motion fails we're back to the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question this is going to be good all
those in favor say I I those oppose
nay
the motion
passes for what reason does a member
rise having voting on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration on hb1 1472
and urge the body to vote
no
present H has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote on the
reconsideration
motion the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill
1472 be a roll call
vote
motion before to reconsider House Bill
1472 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
your oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Khan
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house attend to State the
vote 187 voting a 192 voting a the
motion
fails to
education now we are back to the
education
committee the majority committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1583 FNA an act relative to per
pupil cost of of an opportunity for an
adequate education having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation the bill
ought to pass with Amendment represent
Rick lad for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Mike beler for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0620 printed in house record 7 pages
64-65 the question is are we ready for
the question on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment chair recogniz the
representative
Belair thank you Mr
Speaker
colleagues funding for government
education keeps going
up we are amongst the highest per capita
in the
world yet results outcomes competency
literacy and
numeracy keep going
down let me be the first to tell you
something
counterintuitive more funding is not the
solution more funding is the
problem it's the problem because how
these funds are being
spent more and more administr ative
positions more and more divisive Dei
programming turning classroom
environment into a therapy
session incorporating General Health
Care Services into
schools the path forward to a genuinely
adequate education requires reversing
course on these
Trends cuts to these departments and
staff and returning to
academics the exorbitant funding is the
problem not the solution because schools
have demonstrated time and time again
that when we fund them in excess of what
is necessary to deliver an adequate
education they will use those funds on
programs that are objectively harmful to
their
mission as to the Judiciary some would
make the argument that we have to meet
them halfway
here my message is that our job here is
not to count out to the Judiciary our
job is to secure the powers of this
legislature as delegated To Us by the
Constitution this is a political issue
and this is the political body where
these answers should come from thank
you g recognized representative
lad
thank you very much Mr
Speaker about a month
ago we had these four bills which
they're all Finance bills dealing with
the adequacy funding formula come to
education policy and I went to
leadership and said look if we want to
do this properly we need to have a
subcommittee put together that involves
folks not just from education
policy and Leadership working on both
sides of the aisle here with the
minority leader and the
speaker told me to develop a
subcommittee that had 10 people on it
two from Ways and Means two from finance
and six from policy my modern math says
that's
10 and of the 10 five five Republicans
and five Democrats so we truly have a
bipartisan recommendation that came back
to the
subcommittee or back from the
subcommittee to the education policy
committee and forward with this amending
language we were tasked with the
responsibility of looking at the
formation of a funding
formula that would meet the needs of the
state and analyze previous funding
formulas developed as far back as 2008
in the estherbrook study in the 2018
under the um umberger study and again in
2020 with the commission which we had to
look at the foundation budget
formula we started off with this bill
because this bill addresses a singular
issue when we were provided it base cost
what is the base cost per pupil in
inadequate
education we know based upon what we had
in
2008 that the base cost was
$3,456
3456 and in 2018 it became
3,363
$36 and more recently right now the base
cost per pupil is
$4,180
so we were trying to figure out what is
then the average minimum average salary
for a teacher here in the state of New
Hampshire because that is part of per
pupil base cost back in 2008 the salary
of a teacher was
$33,860
it's a whole lot different what I heard
from the representative from straford
here saying it was 78,000
now is the average medium income or
income for a person in the state today
so we went to work and said okay we need
to find out what the average salary is
right now we went to doe and got a
spreadsheet on every District in this
state what is the minimum salary it
varies tremendously throughout this
state you have some communities where
the minimum salary is over
$60,000
you have others that have 51 to
$58,000 but then you have a few not a
few quite a few and I'm in one of those
towns and people in the North Country
generally are where that salary is
$31,000 now if you're a young person
coming out of unh Keane or Plymouth with
a degree in teaching and it's hard to
find them now seeing that many people
are not wanting to go into the
profession of teaching because there's
no income there to support them in their
daily
life and so those programs are putting
out fewer and fewer teachers that are
prepared to teach in our schools today
and our population though is
declining when I first got on board here
in the house we had over 210,000
students in the state K through 12 we're
down to 154,000
now so what we have to do we looked at
that and we determined that the average
minimum salary for a teacher in this
state right now is$
42,5 60 that's the figure we used so
then we went back to the formula that's
in the base cost as generated in the
esterbrook study back in 2008 where you
have a base cost and you have a what the
cost is the what we call the universal
cost for K through 2 and then grades 3
through 12 we Chang K through two we
felt it should be K through three where
the pupil teacher ratio is 25
to1 and then for grades 4 through 12
it's 30 to1 now I know a lot of
districts aren't there the average is
probably closer to 16 to 171 but that's
not the state's decision making that's a
local decision as to what they're doing
in terms of Staffing in their schools
but when we added that in the cost of a
salary today or what the average is and
also the other factors which are part of
that per pupil base cost including
instruction maintenance Transportation
instructional supplies Media Services
technology Services Counseling Services
the cost of a principal we found out
that that base cost the universal cost
would be
$444 that is
$222 more than what we're paying right
now and when you look at the cost over
what the we're paying for base costs in
our adequacy formula right
now there is an increase of course there
going to be an increase the increase is
$ 34.3
million that in terms of a Educational
Funding which we're talking in the
billions is small stuff but we need to
start moving forward and analyzing what
we're doing with our education formula
in terms of adade
and I feel right now that we brought
forward a reasonable step to move
forward with adequacy funding in the
state you know there's issues going on
outside now in the other branch of
government and we know that there's
other sides of the formula besides base
cost on the right hand side the base
cost is what every student in the state
receives regardless of the community
wealth or poverty that they may be
living in same thing with differentiated
Aid as well but beyond that on the grant
side that's how we make up or try to
make up the differences with how we work
with those small school districts or
those districts which are poverty Laden
that have significant
challenges economy a scale so we've also
included within this package here funds
to support those schools districts and
that is a grant program and you can see
that in the in the report there one of
those programs is based off of poverty
and for those schools that have up to
48% or more poverty in this school I.E
Manchester I.E
Berlin and those down to 12% will
receive support for those
schools changing things are changing in
education today today and yes I know
there's areas that I've dealt with in
the education policy committee which I'm
not pleased with hearing what's going on
but I can tell you I've been in a number
of classrooms and a number of schools
the majority the vast majority of the
Educators out there truly want to help
the
children and they want to get these
basic skills into the kids but we're
also dealing with numerous issues in the
state which we have to deal with one of
which is if you're in in Manchester
right now they have a social worker in
all their schools they have to have that
due to the situation the social skills
kids are arriving with so in conclusion
I'll wrap it up I know we have other
bills coming at us that are dealing with
this
issue this this part of our our plan
here to move forward we need to get it
to finance where they can work the
figures out we have data to show and
reflect why we have recommended what we
are so I'd be pleased to work with them
but I urge this body to forward this
bill to the finance folks division two
so we can move forward thank you very
much representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it's not sufficiently
seconded the question before us is the
majority committee report of aut pass
has amended on House Bill
1583 a division has been requested
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote
e
the motion before us majority committer
report of aut pass as amended on House
Bill 1583 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative beler for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
currently funds
schools to 20,000 in excess dollars per
student on average
if I know that this is a $130 million
spending
bill and if I know that I don't know
that any of this money will go toward
foundational academics if we pass it
would I now press the red button thank
you chair recognize representative luno
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the state school funding formula is a is
unfair to students and property
taxpayers and if I know that this bill
helps districts reduce property taxes
and provide better opportunities for
students then would I press the green
button to vote for the motion of ought
to pass as amended thank
you the motion before us is majority
committee report of Auto pass as amended
andh Bill 1583 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
McKenzie representive
Edwards
all members present had opportunity to
vote how tend to stay the
vote 228 voting y 1550 voting a
committee report is adopted and it is on
its way to
finance CH recognizes a clerk thank you
Mr Speaker just a reminder if you have
not voted when I call your name please
give me a thumbs up or a thumbs down the
buttons will not work because the
station is locked so a thumbs up or
thumbs down if you are unfortunate
enough to have your name called thank
you committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1656 F and local an
act relative to increasing the accuracy
grant for pupils receiving special
Education Services consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
sen Rick lad for the committee the
amendment is 0603 H printed in house
record 7 page 90 and 91 are you ready
for the question on the amendment all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the question before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1656 FN local are you waiting for
the question all those in favor say I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is adopted it's on
its way to
finance majority committee on education
to which was referred House Bill 1675
FNA local act relative to adjusting
education adequacy grants based on pupil
of proficiency consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to
legislator sen of Glenn cordelli for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senator Felicia leakas for the minority
of the committee the chair recognizes
representative Le Alicia
leakas thank you Mr
Speaker half
half of all students are not proficient
in English
language arts 60% are not proficient in
math
70% are not proficient in
science when we bring forth bills to try
to fix this you have parents you have
students showing up and they talk talk
about outcomes and special ed services
and
bullying the other side the government
education side talks about money money
money money and
money so the point of this
bill was to try to speak that language
money so the idea is we want proficiency
we want good outcomes
so the idea is you get your money when
we get our
proficiency we will pay for
that schools every year every year we
give more money to the
schools and yet we haven't seen good
outcomes why is that perhaps schools
aren't focusing and what they need to be
focusing
on I'll use as an example government
Governor Wentworth Regional School
District they recently did a whole
Retreat and everything to try to figure
out what they needed to be focusing on
and to come up with a plan of attack
number one student wellness number two
culture of Wellness number three family
and Community communication and
engagement and finally number four
academic achievement so those first ones
they're going to start working on right
now finally the and 26 and 27 they're
going to start working on
academics you look at what schools are
spending their money on as you heard
before we have Dei seal Wellness
administrators they make twice as much
money as the teachers
do how about if we don't hire them how
about if we give more money to the
teachers how about if we hire math
Specialists and reading Specialists
instead teachers work
hard but they work in a way that isn't
working because they have to pay
attention to what those administrators
are telling them to
do they're not looking at what the
science is for reading no they're
teaching an outdated method that is
actually harmful to
learning they use calculators for
elementary schools instead of teaching
kids multiplication tables and then they
wonder when they have to do factoring
for algebra why they
fail there are a host of issues I'm not
going to take that time I'm just going
to say let's pay for what we want let's
pay for proficiency thank
you chair recognize representative
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker as the majority report States
this is a well-intentioned bill but it
misses the mark the sponsor wants to
link funding to proficiency scores in
hopes of providing a financial incentive
to increase proficiency level
beginning in the school year
2026 districts would get 100% of their
Pew per pupil amount for the prior year
but only
75% of funding for each student below
proficiency so for example if half the
students in one or all of subject areas
are not proficient then half the
students would be funded at at just 75%
of the normal amount or in effect a 25%
reduction in
Aid that percentage would continue to
decrease over the next two years 75%
dropping to
25% so in that third year for a student
not proficient the district will only
get
25% of their normal
funding the net result will be
decreasing funding for all district
because no district and I wish it would
be um the opposite but no district will
be at 100%
proficiency and who will get hurt by
this the students we are trying to help
in the past we have tried a different
approach we tried incentive
grants uh something in our the opinion
of many of us on the committee something
that we should explore further and there
are states that are actually building
incentive grants into their adequacy for
formula for schools and students that
are showing growth show showing academic
increases I think that's the way we
should go rather than penalizing
districts I want to thank the sponsor
for at least bringing attention to our
proficiency rates and the need for
improvement but we need to find a
different path than provided in this
Bill thank
you motion before
is majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislated on House Bill
1675 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
no the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted
what was that
last
J
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1686 FN relative to
requiring excess revenues raised through
the Statewide education property tax to
be remitted to the education trust fund
and prohibiting the Department of
Revenue Administration from setting
negative local and County tax rates on
real
property chair recognize representative
lad for a motion i' like to make a
motion I'd like to table 1686 please the
motion is the table house bill
1686 a division has been requested
members take your
seats
J
e
house house will be in order the motion
before us is to table House Bill
1686 this is a division vote chair
recognize representative lad for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I
know there are similar bills sweat bills
such as this at least three and weighs
the means as to speak right now and if I
know it's timely for us to not deal with
that today to wait till those reports
come back from ways means would I then
press the green
button you recognize representative luno
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill affects all of our
constituents and if I know that this
bill is timely serious and deserves to
be debated today then would I press the
red button so that we can get on with
the debate thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us is to table House Bill
1686 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
I'll
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household tend to stay to the
vote 93 voting yay 181 voting nay
tabling motion
passes for what reason to
mise make a motion State your motion
request the printing of the remarks of
HB
without
objection committee on Election law to
which was referred House Bill 1426 FNA
relative to establishing an advisory
redistricting commission it comes
without
recommendation representative Lane moves
ought to
[Music]
pass the amendment is
0513 H printed in house record 7 page 53
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
thosee
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted we're now on autop pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative
Barry for what reason is member rise to
make a motion State your motion move
inde definitely
postpone because the
amendment
can okay that is a legitimate motion so
the motion before us now is indefinitely
postponed
1426 I are you ready for the question
division has been
requested wheeler requests a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
it'll be a roll call
vote
C
the mo the motion before us is
indefinite post house will be in
order indefinitely postpone House Bill
1426 chair recognize representative
Barry for a parliamentary
inquiry
or
okay thank you Mr Speaker um Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill as presented
would violate our constitutionally
mandated duty to handle our own
redistricting process would I now press
the green button to side with the stance
of the New Hampshire state
constitution do you I recognize we sen
will for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that in
2021 the New Hampshire legislator's
redistricting committees held hearings
in each County but the the actual
drawing of the maps uh were still
conducted Behind Closed Doors Mr Speaker
if I know that the redistricting
commission created in House Bill 1426 is
advisory only and that the legislature
could still would still need to approve
the proposed Maps thereby ensuring the
Bill's
constitutionality then would I now push
the red button so that another motion
can be made thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us is in definely postpone
House Bill
1426 this is a roll call vote you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative Maria Perez
represent all members present had an
opportunity to vote how will attend to
state to the
vote
192 voting aay 186 voting aay definite
postponement
passes
to pass in the amendment so the
amendment will be first no debate on the
amendment we have a debate on the
bill the committee on Election law at
West Jersey faed house spill 1577 FN
relative to digital images of ballots
comes to us without
recommendation representative warry
moves off to pass and offers Amendment
0598 H printed on house record 7 on
pages 63 to
64 questions on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos nay
okay sounds like the eyes have and the
Amendments
adopted motion is now ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1577 representative Lanes recognized
speak against the
motion I think I'm speaking for motion
ought to
pass oh no sorry wrong Bill okay that
was the LA that was the last bill okay
you all right
I think everybody over here kind of went
oh my God all
right so this bill would allow an
unlimited number of citizens to inspect
ballots for a period of four months
after an election under the supervision
of the Secretary of State it allows
independent groups to carry out their
unofficial I'm sorry their unofficial
recounts and tests of voting machines
and will allow access to digital copies
of the ballots because such independent
audit will not follow any regular
procedure their erent and in unreliable
results will erode confidence in
elections not increase it passing this
bill gives Credence to the view that our
elections are rigged and fraudulent it
perpetuates the myth that the 20120 New
Hampshire elections were
unreliable our governor our secretary of
state and the special committee on voter
confidence have all recently expressed
confidence in the security and lack of
widespread Fred fraud sorry in New
Hampshire elections the committee found
that voters most voters have confidence
in our elections New Hampshire elections
are accurate and ballot counting devices
are
reliable in short this bill is not NE
necessary and let me remind you that
virtually all errors that are found in
recounts are due to human errors and not
machine
errors there are plenty of me measures
already in place in our law to safeguard
against errors in our voting vote
counting machines each vote voting
device is tested before each election
each moderator must reconcile the votes
before leaving the polling
location we have multiple
recounts of State Rep and state senate
races each election cycle that will
uncover any issues widespread issues
with the machines in multiple
districts we enacted a new law in
2022 that adopted even more protective
measures for general election recounts
of State Rep races the secretary of
state must also conduct an audit of the
votes cast on those ballots for
president US state senate United States
House of Representatives or governor and
the Secretary of State picks those at
random the SOS must conduct such audit
using the ballots for 10 of the state
representative races to be recounted
these recounts are open to public
viewing I went up and watched some and I
think I was one of maybe 10 people that
went up there to look they're open
they're they're in addition to the
recounts so there's another way to
verify the secretary of state must
conduct a full recount of any race where
there is a discrepancy of greater than
1% from the election results reported to
the Secretary of State also the ballot
accounting devices are con not connected
to the internet so they can't be
hacked this bill will Rec will also
create an enormous administrative burden
on the Secretary of State resulting in
significant new costs that the bill does
not fund for all these reasons I ask
that we vote again against otpa so that
a different motion can be brought and I
ask for a division vote please
representative Barry's recognized to
speak in support of the motion uh thank
you Mr Speaker uh so earlier today we
adopted measures um that would allow for
the introduction of the new voting
machines and I'm not here to rehash that
but one of the things that is cool about
the new voting machines is they use
Digital Imaging versus OCR technology so
in the future we will be able to store
digital images of the ballot and after
the election is certified done and
settled we will have the ability to
upload those and people can go and do
their own citizen audits they can do
their own recounts and the technology
will exist that you will actually be
able to see how the machine counted the
ballot there's further things that are
not in this bill that we could do that
are actually really cool in the future
you might be able to look at your ballot
and no one would know it's your ballot
no one would know only you would know
but you'll be able to see how the
machine counted your ballot
we have to do these things we have to
start having this conversation now I do
appreciate the ranking member from the
other side talking about of granted
stators having faith in the elections
she's right voter confidence in the
election in a UNH survey that came out
yesterday was at an all-time high
unfortunately there's still 23 to 25% of
the voters who have questions and we
need to get that number as low as
possible we the machines are not going
anywhere but let's make them as
transparent as possible so that people
can have confidence
and that's why I urge the body to vote
green op to
pass the question before the house is a
motion of a to pass as amended on House
Bill
1577 representative Sweeney requests a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
e the questions on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1577
and this is a roll call vote
representative Hammer's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill is before its time and if I
know new ballot counting machines are
coming in the near future and if I know
access to digital ballots would be
provided with the new ballot counting
machines coming in the near future then
I would vote against this bill at this
time vote
red thank you representative War's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker honorable
members of the house if I know that one
aspect of voter confidence relies on the
ability of the voters to verify an
election machines accuracy and
reliability if I know that this bill
allows a voter to verify that the
submitted ballot has been interpreted
accurately and correctly and if I know
that the verification process would be
done with transparency under the
supervision of the Secretary of State's
office and finally if I know that the
provisions of this bill would protect
the original ballots and the Machine
election reports would I press the green
button the questions on the motion of
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
1577 and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 193 and the affirmative 182 and the
negative the motion is
adopted House Bill 1577 is referred to
the committee on
finance
the committee on environment and
agriculture to which was referred House
Bill 1184 FNA relative to making an
appropriation to The Organic
certification program comes to us
without
recommendation representative Bixby
moves off to pass representative Kamas
is recognized to speak against the
motion
good afternoon Mr Speaker and honorable
colleagues the New Hampshire Organic
certification program has been in effect
for over 30
years we are only one of only 12 states
that have this type of
program unfortunately it is not
sustainable the cost of this program is
close to14 million
per
year we have over 4,000 farms in the
state of New
Hampshire of those
110 are organically
certified and of
those only 58 are certified through this
program the
program is funded through the end of
this
year
it's not going to harm them for this
growing season but we also know that
there are several options available to
these farms in fact there are over seven
companies currently certifying the other
52 organic crop farms in New
Hampshire is there an increased
cost
yes but the costs will increase under
the Department of Agriculture next year
too because through the Department of
Agriculture there has not been an
increase in over 30 years since the
program
began these Farms have the ability to
have the fees offset through USDA
programs and get reimbursed up to 75% of
the cost of an Organic certification up
to a maximum amount of
$750 I understand that change is
difficult but the agricult cultural
Community is constantly changing no
matter what type of farm you have we in
agriculture are in a constant flux
whether we want to be or
not agriculture is part of New
Hampshire's roots and I value those
routs immensely it is not easy to end a
program but knowing there are several
other options available that those costs
can be offset again through the USD
certification program with grants of up
to
75% is the good
news extending this program for two or
three years will not change the outcome
and the cost of these Farms through the
new Hamp certification program could be
over
$3500 per year which is not
sustainable it is almost triple what
they would pay through a private program
and that is before re re
imbursement and Mr Speaker I would ask
the body to vote r on the otpa mo OTP
motion and I would ask for a division
vote
please representative bixby's recognized
speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker the purpose of HB 1184 is to
strengthen the well reg well well
regarded Organic certification program
in the Department of Agriculture markets
and food sometimes known as
damp the idea of organic agriculture
goes back to the first half of the 20th
century when it was developed as a way
to build soil Health which would in turn
provide crops the nutrients they need
for strong growth organic agriculture
developed a core set of cultural
practices such as using compost to boost
soil organic matter encouraging soil
organisms that make nutrients in organic
matter more available to plants and
avoiding chemical fertilizers and
pesticides that can harm soil organisms
in the the 1970s and 80s organic
agriculture moved from being a tiny
Niche to being a more highly valued
market for its healthy growing methods
seeking higher profits some produc some
producers claimed to be organic while
not actually following organic practices
in order to maintain the Integrity of
the organic label organic farming groups
started certification
programs NOA New Hampshire started such
a program in the mid 1980s the
commissioner of damp at the at the time
Steve Taylor recognized that the that
NOA needed assistance in managing the
program and offered to take it over in
1987 in the 1990s the USDA developed
uniform national standards for organic
labeling which went into effect in the
early
2000s damp became an accredited
certifying agent under the USDA National
organic program at that point the
certification program was run under the
division of regulatory services with
costs partially offset by Fe
for the past two decades the department
has provided USDA organic certification
for New Hampshire's organic farmers and
has earned their trust and their
respect over that period of time
requirements under the national organic
program have become more complicated
which has put increasing Demand on the
department on Department
time HP 1184 provides one and a half
dedicated Organic certification
positions for the Department to make
sure they will be able to Pro provide
the same quality of services that has
earned them this their strong
reputation last fall I had the privilege
to sit in on a couple of listening
sessions no from New Hampshire and the
department held with organic farmers to
get input on how certification should go
forward in New
Hampshire I was struck by the high
praise the department got from the
farmers who talked about how easy the
department was to work with and how
responsive and helpful they are it was
impressive to see how the department had
earned the farmer trust this is echoed
in the farm bureau's letter of support
for the bill damp has a long history as
a certifying agency and a tremendously
valued service provided to to the
state's Farmers one benefit overriding
all other benefits is the agency's
support through providing Organic
certification Services of local
agriculture over the last few decades we
have seen a decline in New Hampshire's
large dairy farms which have been
handicapped by low pricing put in place
by the federal government but we have
seen an increase in small Diversified
Organic Farms that maintain close
connections to their customers we need
to continue to Foster these Farms by
supporting the Department's Organic
certification program and Mr Speaker I
request a division vote thank
you the question before the house is the
motion of a to pass on House Bill 1184
representative kwas requested a division
vote this will be a division vote
members take your seats
you
e
the questions on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 1184 and this is a
division vote representative smarts
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you than you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know New
Hampshire has a total of 4,000 Farms 110
of those are certified organic crops and
out of that 110 only 58 of them are
certified by the New
Hampshire d uh Department of
Agriculture Mr Speaker if I also know
that this bill will cost nearly a
quarter of a million dollars annually
while never being sustainable according
to the Department of Agriculture and
finally Mr Speaker if I know there are
already seven other programs in the
state to certify our organic farmers and
offset their costs please push the red
button to oppose otpa so another motion
can be
made representative wolf is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker if I
know that the Department of Agriculture
has been certifying organic agriculture
since
1987 but in the last 20 years has failed
to increase the fees and if I know that
large Farms are under Decline and are
being replaced by smaller organic farms
and if I know that the consumer is
demanding organic products that are
presently being certified by New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
rather than an outof State
organization and if I know that I want
to approve future funding so that our
organic farmers can continue to provide
the food that our citizens want and
further if I want to see the fees reset
would I then press the green button so
that this motion can pass thank
you the questions on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 1184 and this is
is a division vote if you're in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the
red he's got a long way to
go and voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative golden representative
rning w
je
CER
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 185 in the affirmative 187 in the
negative the motion
fails Aaron representative Aaron moves i
l am I right thank you Mr Speaker yes I
move itl on this
bill representative Aaron moves
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1184 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I all those oppose
[Music]
nay the eyes have it by a
margin
Mr Mr Speaker
Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker for what reason does member rise
Mr Speaker I'd like to move
reconsideration on
this representative Aaron moves
reconsideration
on House Bill
118 what was it 1184 on HB
representative Aaron moves
reconsideration on House Bill
please representative Bixby ask for a
division this will be a division vote
members take your
seats I tell people to vote
now
e
the question is whether to reconsider
the previous vote on House Bill
1184 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor of reconsideration press
the green button if if you're opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative have all members present
and an opportunity to vote the house
will attend to the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 193 in the
negative reconsideration
fails 16
yeah the majority of the committee on
environment and agriculture to which was
referred House Bill 1630 FN an act
relative to Extended producer
responsibility having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resol that it is inexpedient
to legislate representative Judy Aaron
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative Sher
Duty for the minority of the
committee the question is on the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislate representative ger is
recogn hermano is recognized to speak
against the committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker you saved me the
work of saying that I'm up here to speak
against the committee
report I can imagine that many of you
like me spend a lot of hours looking
through the state Solid Waste Management
report and savoring all of the
details uh when you do that you wouldn't
fail to see a triangle in the first few
pages of that text that shows our Solid
Waste Management plan and what our
strategy is supposed to be at the very
top of that triangle what we're supposed
to be doing first and foremost is
reducing the amount of waste that we're
producing in the state at the bottom of
that is landfilling landfilling should
be the last thing that we're doing with
the natural resources of our state and
yet if you take a look at that report
you'll see that that triangle is upside
down the fact of the matter is we use
landfill first first and foremost and
more often than we're using the other
vital elements of our Solid Waste
reduction
strategy our efforts at reductions so
far have proven unfortunately to be
inadequate to say the
least our goal as stated in the 1990
Solid Waste reduction plan was to reduce
our waste by
45% by the year
2050 current projections have us missing
that Mark by more than
50% by the middle of this
Century onethird of the waste that we
continue to put into our landfills comes
from
packaging this bill would establish an
extended producer
Responsibility program the bill is
definitely complicated because the
problem is complicated it's
multifaceted the subject needs more more
study and so what I am here to do today
Mr Speaker is to ask my colleagues to
vote against the itl motion so that we
can send this to an interim study
committee where we can start to look at
specific pieces of eppr taken as a whole
it is enormous it is complicated is it
is difficult but we can start to make
progress in the direction of our stated
Solid Waste Management goals if we start
to take it apart one piece at a time and
an interim study would allow us to take
a more concentrated approach to the
problem the key word I think in this
phrase extended producer
responsibility is
responsibility each and every one of us
as individuals has responsibility the
kind of unspoken very top of that
triangle that I referred to earlier is
actually refuse that is that each of us
has a responsibility I would argue to
ref refuse to contribute to the waste
production to find ways not to consume
things that are going to have to end up
in our waste management system that's
the very first thing that we can do and
each of us has a responsibility to do
that this legislative body which
approves which uh looks at studies and
approves the goals set in that Solid
Waste Management plan we have a
responsibility to the constituents who
sent us here to get at least a lot
closer to the the Target that we
promised them that we would hit in 1990
and we are more than 50% off from
hitting by the year
2050 but producers also have a
responsibility there is at this point in
time some effort on the part of some
producers to reduce the packaging but
the fact that we are still looking at a
third of what's going into our landfill
coming from packaging and we all know it
we all see it whenever you order from a
company and you get the packaging you
can see how much wastefulness there is
and you can project that across the
citizens of the Granite State and get
some idea of what it is that we're
putting in our
landfills we have to acknowledge our
responsibility but we also have to
expect the producers to live up to their
responsibility and so Mr Speaker I ask
my colleagues in the house please vote
against the itl motion so that we can
move ahead with an interim study which
will allow us to take a big problem a
complicated problem and to look at it in
more discret parts so that we can take a
step in the direction of living up to
our responsibility of a legislative body
to serve the interests of the people who
sent us here thank you Mr Speaker I ask
for a division
vote representative aens recognized to
speak in support of the committee
report
thank you Mr
Speaker dear friends and
colleagues HB
1630 would establish an extended
producer Responsibility program in New
Hampshire while we all recognize that
improved recycling is important as is
keeping toxic substances out of our
landfills the truth is this bill is too
broad and that epr legislation should be
enacted carefully and in a more targeted
peace this
legislation and I'm sorry this
legislature is already working on
diverting food waste and hazardous
materials from our landfills we've had
17 landfill bills in my committee and
we're studying ways to accomplish our
waste reduction
goals this Bill had many con concerning
provisions and it would also cost our
taxpayers between a milon
$1,624 th000 a year to
administer this bill sets up a huge
state bureaucracy with great Reliance on
the Department of Environmental Services
for
administration as well as establishing a
packaging reduction organization there's
absolutely no guarantee that the
proposals in this bill will accomplish
the goals it sets forth and it also
establishes unattainable standards it
will also have significant impact to
consumers in our state by Banning
specific critical products from being
used or sold in New Hampshire other
states like Maine have embarked on this
type of extensive epr program and they
have encountered many problems in its
implementation
which after a lot of time and taxpayer
money invested is still not
functional in New Hampshire we are
already looking at managing and reducing
Solid Waste going into our landfills and
through other pieces of legislation
additionally our legislator's Solid
Waste working group is seeking ways to
accomplish waste reduction through
suggested legislation as it works with
legislators stakeholders waste haulers
and state
Regulators so please join me in pressing
the green button to itl this costly and
unnecessary Bill thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1630
FN hey does a member yield for a
question sure
thank you Mr Speaker uh thank you uh
representative for taking my question
given that the vast majority of consumer
products consumed in New Hampshire are
in fact produced out of state and
produced on a national scale for all 50
states would it be appropriate to say
that an Erp program really is a state
tax on packaging that gets applied to
the business that produces the goods but
yet gets downshifted onto consumer goods
costs of the
consumer yes you consider you can
consider it that
way
follow does the member yield for another
question thank you Mr speaker thank you
uh for taking my my question given that
the vast majority of consumer products
are made on a national scale wouldn't an
Erp program be epr program be more
appropriate at the federal level
shouldn't it be a federal responsibility
instead of each state setting up their
own uh fifs that that then companies
have to navigate 50 different uh sets of
rules well with regard to packaging and
labeling and that kind of thing it seems
to make sense that some of that would
have to be accomplished through Federal
legislation um and yeah you there's a
possibility of uh 50 different states
coming up with 50 different kinds of
plans could complicate a lot of things
thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of in expedience to
legislate on House Bill 1630 and this is
a division vote members take your
seats
e
supp
is
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1630 this is a division vote
representative NAB is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the minority of the
committee is in support of an interim
interim study of this issue not the
under L epr Bill and its related
expenses and I also know that extended
producer responsibility is an important
means of reducing our dependency on
landfills reducing the toxins in our
waist stream and decreasing the
substantial expenses our towns facing
tipping fees and deserve serious study
would I then press the red button so
that another better motion can be made
thank
you representative Davis has recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this bill though well-
intended would cost the state between a
million to approximately a milon 600,000
annually to
administer and Mr Speaker if I know this
there is no guarantee that the proposals
in this bill will accomplish the goals
set forth and that it sets up
unattainable standards and Mr Speaker
lastly if I also o know that other
states like Maine have embarked on
extensive epr programs like this one and
have encountered many problems in its
implementation and after a lot of time
and money invested is still not
functional then Mr Speaker would I press
the green button to itl this Bill thank
you the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpediency
legislate on House Bill 1630 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 199 and the affirmative 176 and the
negative the committee reports
adopted
might as well stay in your seats there's
no debate on this
one the majority of the committee on
environment and agriculture to which was
referred House Bill 16 ADN and acts
relative to prohibiting the sale of dogs
and cats by retail Pet Shops having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Kelly prenza for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Sher Dusty for the
minority of the committee representative
Bixby requests a division vote this will
be a division is requested a roll oh
look at that representative grer
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
1680 representative dust is recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
believe that there is no Silver Bullet
to the problem with out of-state puppy
mills but that hb680 is a good start and
if I believe that
hb680 respects New Hampshire's tradition
of supporting businesses by Grand
fathering the five pet stores currently
selling dogs and cats until their
business is finally
sold and if I know that animal ownership
requires
commitment um that and that it is time
to move to stop the emotional marketing
of dogs and cats to children would I now
press the red button so another motion
can be made thank
you representative Penza is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know the focus
of legislation should not be attacking
or Banning pet retail stores in New
Hampshire but rather regulating the
sourcing of these animals for resale and
if I know the biggest concerns we heard
from the public were a potential
sourcing
problem puppy mills not a pet store
problem and if I know that this bill
punishes all versus gets to the heart of
the issue people were most upset with
and if I further know that passing this
bill would eliminate future private
businesses that are fully regulated and
are required to follow All State and pet
health certificate laws then Mr Speaker
would I then press the green button to
itl this legislation thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of in expedience to
legislate on House Bill 1680 FN
if you are in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
Richard representative
trip
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 260 in the affirmative 117 and
negative the committee reports
adopted the committee on executive
departments and administration in which
is referred to House Bill 1307 FM FN an
act providing a supplemental
appropriation for members of the
retirement system receiving an
accidental disability retirement
allowance having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Fred Davis for the
committee the question is on Amendment
0510 H printed on house record 7 on page
50 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment's adopted the questions
now on the majority report of uh to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
report's
adopted and it is referred to the
committee on
finance
the committee on executive departments
Administration to which was referred
House Bill 1394 FNA relative to lure and
regulation of Music therapists and
making an appropriation therefore comes
to us without recommendation
representative gold moves ought to pass
and offers Amendment 0399 H which is
printed in House Records 7 on pages 51
through
53 the question is on adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now the question is on the
motion of ought to pass with Amendment
representative Maguire is recognized to
speak against the
motion thank you Mr Speaker you may all
remember this from last year year or the
year before possibly five years ago
we've heard it
before and what was notable about the
testimony and the discussion this year
is that the music therapists did not say
we need to have a license so that we can
keep we can set minimum standards and
keep unqualified people from practicing
in the
state they also did not say we need to
have a license so we will have a way to
discipline misbehaving or
incompetent practitioners it's a protect
Public Safety no they didn't mention
that the reason they want a license is
that their customers don't want to pay
full price or for their services so that
they want to have a license so they can
build Medicaid they can build Medicare
they can build the V build the VA and
they can can build private insurers for
their services that's the only reason
they brought forward this
legislation and I don't think it's an
appropriate use of State Authority and
Licensing which is intended to protect
the public safety to bring it in so that
the practitioners have a more convenient
way to get
reimbursed um please vote against ought
to
pass representative gouls recognized to
speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker this bill establishes The Lure
and regulation of Music therapists under
the office of professional licensure and
certification the committee heard a lot
of testimony about the value the service
offers residents most notably our
veterans we heard a lot of detail about
the fact that this is a science and that
when applied inappropriately by people
who have not been trained properly in it
in fact is harmful it's not just
enjoying music
lightly so lure is an important part of
it without licensing clients cannot use
their insurance to pay for a service
that notably improves their well-being
and it's especially important to our
veterans a similar bill passed this
house last year some changes found
enough support to clear on the other
side of the wall too
it's stalled in Committee of conference
we believe this amended bill will make
it through the general court into law
please join us by pressing the green
button for OTP for the with the
amendment thank
you the questions on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1394
representative Granger requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
get
the questions on the motion of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 1394 and
this is a roll call vote representative
Simons recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that music therapists have
been practicing music therapy safely and
effectively in the state of New
Hampshire for years and if I know that
the purpose of lure is to protect the
public from harm and furthermore Mr
Speaker if I know the misuse of lure in
HB 1394 even if with good intentions
will create unjustifiable bureaucratic
oversight Force practitioners to pay
unnecessary fees and file burdis some
forms and will unfairly forbid them from
practicing unless they comply would I
then press the red button so that a
better motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker representative Gro is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the house passed this
bill last year as did the Senate
but in an unfortunate circumstance in
the committee of conference the house
support was not honored and if I want to
send a message to the house from the
house that we support this bill and we
support not only Public Safety but the
reputation and the workmanship of these
professionals please vote Yes on autop
pass thank
you the questions on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill
1394 and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the
vote 194 in the affirmative 186 the
motion is
adopted and the and 1394 is referred to
the committee on
[Music]
finance
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
House Bill 1466 FN act relative to
providing disaster relief funding to
municipalities after a natural disaster
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Carol Maguire for the
committee the amendment is
0528 H printed in house record 7 page 56
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the members the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is adopted and it's
going to
finance committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred house Bill 1647 FNA act
relative to the calculation of group two
retirement benefits in the retirement
system consider the same report the same
with the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment so Carol Maguire for the
committee amendment is
0326 H printed in house record 7 Pages
86 through 87 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted and it's on
its way to
finance majority of the committee on
executive departments Administration to
which was referred House Bill 1689 FN
act relative to the use of personal
identifying information by state
agencies considered the same report the
same with recommendation that the bill
be referred for interim study sen of JC
Grody for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass president Matthew San
dasto for the minority of the
committee the motion before us now is
the committee report of referred to for
interim study are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is
adopted committee on Health and Human
Services in Elo Affairs to which was
referred houseal Bill 1303 FN act
relative the estate of teski bana having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sen Lucy Weber for
the committee the amendment is
054 8h printed in house record 7 Pages
50 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the question before
us now is ought to pass with the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I suppose nay
the eyes have have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's going to Ways
and
Means
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1593 FN act relative
to funding for developmental Services
Community integration having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation to Bill AO pass with
Amendment sen Amicon for the
committee the amendment is
0709 H printed in house record 7 page 65
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is a to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance committee on Health and Human
Services and La Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1669 FN act relative
to redistricting data sharing through
the state imization registry consider
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment s of Gary Merchant for
the committee the amendment is 0619 H
printed in house record 7 page 91 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance move on pass in the Amendments
INF speak against the
amendment
am
house be in
order committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative services to whichard for
House Bill 1178 FN relative to employees
unused earned
time sen Michael kahill moves ought to
pass and offers floor
Amendment
0783 H it's in your seat Pockets chair
recognized representative timee to speak
against the committee amendment that
we're on the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker hey I
don't want everyone to leave we have a
lot of real fun stuff coming up here in
the labor committee so you
know
hello the how the house of in order the
member has a right to speak I don't want
everyone to go out in the anti- room
because you're going to miss all kinds
of fun stuff coming up for labor
committee
so I rise in opposition to the amendment
being
proposed a bill this type of legislation
has been front of been in front of us at
least six or seven times in the last 10
years
I've tried to work with my fellow labor
committee members and we're close to
having an agreement but we're not quite
there yet one of the problems with this
amendment if you want to look um the one
fourth paragraph down Roman numeral
5A I was okay with the the sentence
about uh providing these benefits for
employees or employee business closes or
a changes
ownership but the next sentence is
something I just can't live
with with no reasonable
assurances you're you're you're um
unemployed for no reasonable assurances
of employee being you being return to
work when we make these laws these are
laws that need to be interpreted by the
Department of Labor and then hearings
officers reasonable insurance is is like
you know it's not something we should be
doing in the legislature something
that's so
vague
[Music]
the thing about New Hampshire is it and
and like most States no business is the
same and we're trying to put everything
into one simple package here when every
business is not one simple package CPAs
for instance they tell their employees
you can't take any time off between
January and April 15th a lot of people
in the hospitality industry the same
thing around the Thanksgiving to the
Christmas holiday there's one company in
Manchester that makes uh chocolates I'm
sure you all know them they close down
the entire month of June to retool their
Factory what if
you're uh lay asphalt for a living well
you know basically from December till
March you're not going to have any
work so we're trying to put all of these
things into one package and you just
can't
and reasonable Assurance really doesn't
help it doesn't give the Department of
Labor what they
need so I would ask that you vote uh
down this
amendment um and I'm going to ask for a
roll call Mr
Speaker chair recogniz President Michael
kill thank you Mr Speaker and I'd like
to thank uh
my good friend Mr infantine for raising
some of the points that he did because
this amendment is is based largely on
this idea that there are no no one
simple solution no blanket
rules um in fact the the language that
he's referenced to uh changed ownership
or because their employment ended with
no reasonable Assurance of the employee
being able to return to said employer
that's that's because of the people
working out there Paving roads that was
brought to my attention by uh a lobbyist
who represents that that industry and
because you can't just say um lay off
because they intend to come back to that
job and that's why they have a reason
they have an assurance that they're
coming back when the season permits it's
not going to be a certain date because
our weather is kind of mish AAS right
now but uh it's that's why that phrase
is there and got that language from the
gentleman in OS who happens to have
recently worked as a wage claim officer
so this language is subject to
interpretation but fairly easy to
interpret if I if my employer says uh
I'll see you next see you in the spring
that means I have a reasonable
assumption that I'm coming back and I
have the option of having the vacation
stay there or be or perhaps be paid off
if if that's what the the people want to
do
now I'm not even sure if Paving
Contractors offer vacation because they
want people out there Paving every day
they can but anyway we're not just
talking about Paving operators we're
talking about all kinds of jobs all
kinds of employers and there may be
people who shut down for two weeks and
and everybody gets the same vacation
that's fine no problem here but perhaps
looking back at your own work history
maybe you've been in that situation
where they say we're having a
meeting and whether or not the company
is sold you if the company was sold you
would think you probably had the
opportunity to continue on with the new
owner because you knew the job you were
doing the job well and the new owner
wanted to keep trained people you that's
probably what happened in most cases or
your your vacation that you had earned
that maybe acred or given uh all all
front loaded was paid to you it wasn't
take it didn't disappear from that final
paycheck so we agree uh Mr
representative infantine and I the
previous speaker agree that when you
change when when the company closes or
changes ownership you certainly should
pay your help because they had you know
nothing to do with this they're not at
fault they're not fired and and uh
that's the right thing to do that's what
happens often but it doesn't have to
happen because in New Hampshire uh the
employer can just say in their policy
that
uh I I don't upon
termination vacation isn't paid and it
doesn't matter if you the employee of
the month through three straight months
uh you worked there for six years it
doesn't matter that's the policy if you
file a wage claim you will
lose and again the uh I have examples
I've cited this
before uh in my community an assisted
living center changed hands and the
owner had that policy so the five people
that bothered to file wage claims that
took it upon themselves to think well
this can't be right this this isn't fair
um they lost combined
2261 and 44 cents all stayed in the
owner's pocket nothing was no adjustment
was made to allow them to continue they
did continue with the new employer but
what was missing was this
$2,200 now ask yourself if that's what
you would do if it was your company or
that's what you would want to have
happen if it was your
employer uh another case uh person was
working for a company I think seven
years and all of a sudden there was a
layoff and because she had several weeks
of vacation
accured uh but she lost like
$2,300 because she had no notice and
therefore was not able to request the
vacation with two weeks advance notice
now that's catch
22 uh you you you can't win you lose you
lose because you can't do you can't do
the other that that's required and the
employer gave no opportunity to do that
so you have people who are going to work
with the idea that what they're told is
you have this vacation whether it's uh
ACR or front loaded uh and you have it
it's yours you're earning it's it's you
know so much so much ACR per week it's
yours and then all of a sudden something
happens beyond your control
uh you weren't fired but now your job is
over or it Seas or it's your or you're
coming back that's another situation you
can work that out with your employer but
in this situation where uh the employer
says I'm not paying you because I don't
have to I don't think we want to have
that in New Hampshire and I'd ask you to
approve the amendment and then approve
the bill so that we can stop doing this
every year thank
you tine has requested a roll call is
that official ly
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
EX
members will be in their
seats the motion house will be in
order
the motion before us is the kill floor
Amendment 0783 H this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
infantine for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if you know as I do
that the term reasonable assurances is
vague and up to various
interpretations if you know that this
law this amendment tries to pre
preempt business's employee manuals
which is not something I think our
legislature should
do also Mr Speaker if I feel that this
bill and this amendment are not ready
and I know they will have a reasonable
assurances they probably will not pass
the other side of the wall would I vote
no on this
amendment chair recognize representative
kill for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that uh this legislation
similar legislation has passed this body
several times over the recommendation of
the
committee and that I have made a
substantial change from the last time
and received a uh neutral from people
from the stakeholders who were
previously opposed it and Mr Speaker if
if I know that uh whether whether you've
lost your job through a
layoff the business being sold or a
change of ownership you should not
forfeit that which you've earned which
is your earned time would I now vote
green thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us the kill
floor Amendment 0783 H this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote househ will tend to stay to the
vote 199 voting aay 179 voting aay the
floor amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I
I those oppose nay
[Applause]
[Music]
a division has been requested for
clarification
only only members that are in the
chamber at this point can vote the
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended this is a clarification vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
representative Bolton
represent
bton all members present have an
opportunity to vote houseold attend to
stay the
vote 198 voting a 180 voting aay
committee report is adopted and it's
going to
finance
committee on labor industrial and real
data services to which is referred House
Bill 1322 FN relative the state minimum
hourly rate comes it out recommended
repr stab moves ought to pass chair
recognizes representative infant
infantine
yes hey well that was fun let's keep
going
it this bill proposes to increase the
minimum
wage from up to $17 an hour by
2029 so I did some research we all drive
through we see advertisements that said
you know say x doll per hour so I looked
at three kind of starting type
jobs McDonald's
Haniford supermarkets and uh Dunkin
Donuts and I looked on their state of
the New Hampshire your web page to see
all the jobs that are open for each one
of these
positions I didn't see a wage starting
wage lower than $16 an hour at
McDonald's Hannah fer is between 15 and
22 for uh baggage and and checkout
clerks Duncan's the lowest at between $
13 and
$18 so I would suggest that New
Hampshire employers are already doing
this themselves they know what they need
to do to
employees New Hampshire does a lot of
things that other states you know
doesn't do a lot of things other states
do we don't have a bottle Bill why
because we recycle
ourselves we don't have a mandatory
insurance law but more people in New
Hampshire have insurance than in states
where it's mandatory employers know what
they have to do to get
employees the second part of the bill
that is disconcerting to me has to do
with the that this bill will increase
every year with a New England Consumer
Price
Index nothing for negative inflation but
just for you know on a positive scale
positive inflation you know I've always
believed I was taught this a long time
ago I've been hanging around these halls
for almost 20 years now and when I was a
young buck someone told
me we
don't shy away from our responsibilities
to vote on things we don't let things
just happen
every year
automatically I don't think we we should
be passing something where increases
happen
automatically I don't like it when the
United States Congress walks around and
gets a raise every year and says oh we
didn't vote for it it was automatic in
New Hampshire we
vote so I would appreciate I'm I would
like a roll call Mr Speaker but I'm
asking my colleagues to vote against
this
bill chair recognized representative sty
thank you Mr Speaker our rise today in
support of the ought to pass motion on
House Bill
1322 this bill would gradually raise New
Hampshire's minimum wage beginning with
an increase to
$99.50 followed by Modest yearly
increases until it reaches $17 an hour
in
2029 and then after that increases
yearly based on the CPI which is what
the states of Vermont and Maine do why
$17 you might ask the MIT living wage
calculator estimates that
$17.23 an hour is what a single person
needs to live a decent life in New
Hampshire and isn't that what we want
for all Granite
Staters it is true that our current
labor shortage has given workers The
Leverage to demand higher wages but
there's still one group of workers who
can make
$725 an hour tipped workers
if a waitress in New Hampshire comes in
on a quiet day and doesn't make much in
tips the employer is required to make up
their wages to the minimum wage of a
mere
$725 that same waitress would make $15
for her time in Massachusetts and
$14.15 in Maine and aren't our workers
worth as much as workers in
Massachusetts and Maine New Hampshire
has not raised it minimum wage in 15
years every state around us has by a lot
and their economies have not
collapsed if we want to grow our state's
economy we need to attract and retain
working people reestablishing and
raising the minimum wage sends the
message that we value our workers and
that New Hampshire is a place where they
can make a living and enjoy a good
quality of life Mr Speaker when I vote
for this bill I will will be thinking of
the people who will benefit most the
waitress who fills your coffee cup on a
quiet Tuesday Morning the people who
keep the convenience stores and gas
stations open so you can get a gallon of
milk when you need it or fill your tank
when you come rolling in on fumes and
the home health aid who comes every
morning to help your elderly neighbor
get out of bed make sure she takes her
medication and has a at least one good
meal that day if you believe as I do
that the
124,000 workers in New Hampshire who
make less than $17 an hour are important
contributors to our state's economy and
enhance the quality of life for all of
us then I urge you to press the green
button and raise the wage thank you Mr
Speaker representative intine has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
for
e
C
also be in
order the motion before us is aut to
pass on House Bill
1322 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes the representative
infantine for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
employers know what they need to do to
attract
employees and a vast majority are paying
more per hour than what is proposed in
this
legislation and Mr Speaker if I also
know that this bill is tied to automatic
increases with the New England consumer
price index
index and I don't feel that the
legislature should have automatic
increases we should sit and vote on any
increases what I vote no on this Bill
thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Schultz for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that a strong
capitalism and a strong New Hampshire
means we don't pay workers so poorly
that they have to go on public
assistance and if I know that too many
workers can't afford rent food in the
simple
Basics and instead of liberal wages for
124,000 low-wage workers probably in
every District in the
state and if I know that with no minimum
wage of our own we default to the
federal
$725 an hour the wealthiest state to do
so and half of what all of New England
does besides
us and Mr Speaker if I know that
hardworking Granite Staters are counting
on us to make that horrible phrase
Working Poor a relic of the past by
pushing the green
button thank you the motion before us is
auto pass on House Bill 1322 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e represent
Richards all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 187 voting yay 192 voting nay the
motion
fails for what reason is the member rise
uh I move indefinitely
postpone
it is a proper motion so the motion
before us now is to indefinitely
postpone House Bill
1322 are you ready for the
question a division has
been come down come
down Mr Speaker I'd like to move to
table this legislation thank you that is
a higher priority so the motion now will
be to table House Bill
1322 I'm assuming a division require is
holding for this one too so this will be
a division
vote members will remain in your
seats we're all
set
sure
okay the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1322 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household attendance state to
the
vote 189 voting yay 191 voting nay the
motion to table
fails back to the motion of indefinite
postponement on House Bill
1322 V this is a division
vote and everybody is still in their
seats very
good so the motion before us is inde
definely postpone House Bill
1322 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
is
[Music]
represent har
cther represent
fber all members pres opportunity to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote
193 voting a 187 voting a the indefinite
postponement of HB 1322
passes Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker for what reason house will be in
order for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I would move the the
remarks on uh how spill 1322 be printed
in the permanent journal without
objection committee on labor industrial
and rehabilitative services to which was
referred House Bill 1377 FN relative to
granting work as
free granting workers free choice to
join join or refrain from joining labor
unions this comes without
recommendation Z
Mr
Speaker for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I move to indefinitely postpone House
Bill
1377 motion is in
order representative Sweeney requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
vote
it's good enough
now did a
screen
the house of me in order
wait
CH recogniz her absent of
Granger thank you Mr Speaker this
legislation is called right to work but
it should be more it would be more
accurate to call it the right to work
and not have money from your paycheck
stolen by people who have crippled your
ability to independently negotiate who
then
act like they've done you a favor by
doing so that's a bit long-winded but
you get the point I am an independent
worker I do not work in a union job I
come from a long line of proud
independent workers who also do not take
union jobs
I'm someone who isn't in a union and
also supports right to work it's a
change of pace for this
legislation labor laws can be confusing
so I'll provide a fairly clear example
of why I support right to work let's say
you work for a company and the workers
form a union you're not in the union but
they form a
union let's say the union chooses the
union chooses the member will be in
order let's no talk
about let's say that the union chooses
for exclusive representation that means
that they represent all employees even
non-union employees the union chooses
that question for you how would you go
about independently negotiating your own
wage and benefit package directly with
the company answer you can't it's
illegal you are not allowed to negotiate
your own wages you are not allowed to
negotiate your own benefit package as an
independent depent worker you have had
your agency stolen from you by Union
that will then come to the labor
committee and then call you a free rider
they will come to my committee and they
will come in droves to complain about
independent workers like me who are Free
Riders because we get the negotiated
wage that they negotiated for them even
if we don't want it even if we don't
want their benefit package even if we
value our independence more than their
handouts they will come over and call
you a free rider so regardless of how
this vote goes know this evil is
self-defeating private sector L labor
unions who have relied on this
Antiquated peculiar institution to stay
alive are slowly disappearing there was
a Time in America when almost half of
all the workers were in a union we've
now gotten to the point where the unions
have driven away the majority of those
they represent and now only 10% of
workers are in a union what more most of
these workers are in the public sector
which already has right to work thanks
to the Janice decision on top of that
not every private sector Union engages
in the practice of forcing non-union
members to subsidize the unions some
actually try to provide a decent service
to their members without needlessly
resorting to throwing independent
workers under the bus we will bring this
bill back every two years until it
either passes or until this unethical
practice stops if you want to not listen
to this debate ever again please oppose
the indefinite postponement thank you
the motion before us is indefinitely
postponed the motion before us is
indefinitely postpone House Bill
1377 this is a roll call
vote please speak in favor
chair recognized representative L
Clark thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
might not have as much experience here
in the state house as most of you but I
do have experience in opposing this
Right to Work bill as I've been a
carpenter in the carers union for 28
years
now I reached to WS they asked when
Right to Work legislation was first
introduced to this body it was told that
the first substantia bill was introduced
in
1979 when introduced I was 16 going on
17 years old but didn't do much about
unions except that my dad was a member
of the
teamsters he was a root salesman for
Sunbeam bread working out of Cody
Brothers Bakery in Manchester and uh if
you grew up in and around Manchester you
might have gone down South Elm Street
roll your windows down and smell fresh
baked bread
it was awesome I remember those
days so in 1980 I earned my PhD that's
my public high school
diploma from Manchester Memorial High
School I only mention this because at
the time the teamsters were having
issues with those that were not in favor
of unions I don't remember all the
details but I do know that my dad got
called to write shotgun literally in
case an overnight delivery got
interrupted because of this he missed my
high school graduation now you might be
thinking why would a father miss their
oldest son's graduation and you know
what I kind of thought that too but then
we talked about it when he got home and
I understood that he did what he had to
do he obviously didn't want to miss my
high school graduation but he also
didn't want to lose what was fought by
so many before him those who had made
huge sacrifices for the greater good he
was proud of the fact that being a
Teamster allowed him to provide for his
wife and four sons and was not about to
let anyone won't take that away from him
when I graduated from trade school a few
years later he was able to make that he
remained a Teamster even when he changed
um careers and started working for the
Manchester Police Department we lost him
in 2011 after fighting long and hard
against two different cancers and then
finally succumbing to
leukemia at the rip old age of 66 by the
way just one month before he was going
to
retire thanks to the MPD and the
teamsters his benefits paid for all the
medications and treat treatments he had
to deal with along the way they stayed
by his side until the end and because
his wife was able to receive his pension
she was able to stay in their home until
we lost her just a little over a year
ago in 1995 my wife Francine and I had
our Second Son I'd been working in
construction for open SHOP Company since
the mid 80s before during and after
going to trade school I was tired of
begging for lame raises and getting
terrible benefits that I had to pay for
my wife and I with a wife and two young
Sons I knew that I needed to make a
change my brother-in-law had just joined
the Carpenters Union suggested I'd do
the same so I
did my only regret was that I waited
till I was 33 years old and didn't do it
at 23 years old fast forward to today
I'm 61 years old this close to retiring
I have a full pension in annuity waiting
for Francine and me to carry us through
our retirement years I've been paying
dues
voluntarily for all those years because
I know the rate of return we'll receive
cannot be matched by any financial
institution there's no way we could have
saved up what we're going to get in our
retirement years this legislation
jeopardizes all of that even with its
misleading title we can all agree that
everyone has the right to work but I
really hope that everyone in this room
knows that this bill has nothing to do
with that make no mistake the only
intent of HB 1377 is to destroy unions
and what many many long before us have
fought and died for safe wages safe
working conditions and a chance to
retire with dignity just to name a few
even though the federal government
already protects workers Freedom not to
join a union HB 1377 wants to give some
workers a free ride by allowing anti-un
workers to opt out of paying any fees
but still be able to receive all the
benefits and by law Union representation
would still be provided even a
business's largest Planet Fitness would
not survive if nobody paid fees to be a
member during the two days of hearings
at the labor committee the best
Committee in the house Mr
Speaker we heard we heard testimony from
the executive director for Northeast
citizens for Right to Work who are
really from
Virginia his written testimony stated
the facts show businesses are naturally
inclined to locate new jobs in and when
feasible transfer existing jobs to
states where right to work is protected
when we asked for proof none was
provided we do know that Republican
Governor Jim Justice pushed to pass a
right to work law promising he would
bring new jobs but in February of 2021
about half an hour or so into a town
meeting he admitted really and truly
let's be brutally honest we passed the
right to work law in West Virginia and
we ran to the windows looking to see all
the people that were going to come and
they didn't
come last Thursday during the State of
the State address Governor sonunu said
that many businesses have come to New
Hampshire and were not a right to work
state and as of February 13 2014 I mean
2024 just last week after 50 plus years
of being a right to work state Michigan
is no longer a right to work
state we also heard from the president
CEO the house will be in order thank you
Mr Speaker we also heard from the
president and CEO of associated builders
and contractors that's the ABC who
represents many dues paying construction
firms he testified that in New Hampshire
union bosses use violence coercion and
intimidation to force people to join
unions as a former Union
boss I uh resent those
remarks and again when asked for proof
none was brought forth I'd like to point
out that our union bosses here in New
Hampshire have helped many open shop
Carpenters get compensation owed to them
working with the state do we got them
the money they earn sometimes thousands
because we believe in protecting all
workers rights and when you work you get
paid Union or not the ABC also testified
that Union construction workers can only
make with their contract States and need
to beg the union boss for more money
again hurtful but not
true the rate of pay in our contract is
a minimum amount if a carer would like
to earn more he or she can work with
their employer to do so no Union boss
involved by the way Union corporate's
minimum wage is way higher than the open
shop Center's minimum wage of 725 an
hour colleagues let's be clear the
reality is that right to work isn't just
wrong for New Hampshire workers it's
also wrong for New Hampshire businesses
at the hearings and through
correspondence we heard from firms that
employ thousands of New Hampshire
workers they were clear in telling us
that right to work is bad for business
because it will intrude in their
business's ability to freely negotiate
contracts that they determine are in
their best interest to their
companies they expressed dismay that
here in New Hampshire the Live Free or
Die state that this legislative body
would pass a law that mandates
government interference in the free
market they also point pointed out that
passing right to work will harm our
communities because studies show states
that have passed Right to Work have
lower wages higher rates of job site
injuries and death lower rates of Health
Care coverage and higher rates of
poverty pushing more people toward
Public Assistance is not something they
and I hope we can all agree is not good
for our state Mr Speaker I could
continue pointing out the untruths told
by the folks in favor of right to work
but I would like to just point out two
more things before closing
first while executing hp37 it was said
in the best Committee in the house that
unions are irrelevant and probably won't
be around in 50 years if that was true
why the hell are so many anti-union
organizations like the afor mention
working so diligently and spending so
much money to get rid of them I'll wager
my entire gross salary for this session
that the members of this house receive
more correspondence in opposition to
this Bill from True voting New Hampshire
constituents than those in support I'm
confident in this wager because more
than after more than 5 hours of P
testimony over two days more than 1,400
members of the public either spoke or
registered their opposition to
1377 while less than 50 spoke in
positive secondly this body gets
together to debate and vote on whether
or not a bill introduced from committee
should become law typically bad bills go
no further no matter how many times
times or in what form they're introduced
in my opinion and the opinion of
legislators over the past 40 plus years
no matter which side had the majority
this is once again a bad Bill that
should not go any further Mr Speaker I
respectfully ask that we all push the
red button I mean the green button to
indefinitely
postpone like so many before us at the
request of our voting New Hampshire
constituents let's all prove again that
right to work in HB 1377 are wrong for
New Hampshire wrong for New Hampshire
businesses and wrong for all the
taxpayers of this great state of New
Hampshire Mr Speaker I also respectfully
ask for a division vote it's already a
roll
call the
motion members take your seats this is
going to be a roll call
vote the motion before us is inde
defitely postpone House Bill 1377 it's a
roll call vote
Che so go
the motion before us is definitely
postponement for House Bill 1377 this is
a roll call vote chair recognized
representative Brian Sullivan for parli
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
excuse me Mr Speaker if I know that this
body has been killing right to work for
over 40
years and if I know that over 1,400
people signed in in opposition to right
to work and only 50 signed in in favor
of it and if I know that right to work
is wrong for New Hampshire then would I
press the green button in favor of
indefinite postponement thank you chair
recognize represent P papuchi Miller for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that many
workers do not want a union job and this
bill protects the right of every worker
to choose to join a union and pay for
their services or not if I know that
this bill would eliminate restrictions
on the freedoms of indid individuals and
businesses alike allowing them to choose
what is best for them without being
coerced into different choices
if I know that the so-called Free Riders
are a myth since the nlr explicitly
allows unions to negotiate members only
contracts which do not require unions to
represent non-members and lastly if I
know that there is no doubt that forcing
someone to pay to exercise a
constitutional right is a clear
interference with their rights would I
then press the red button so that a
better motion could be
made the motion before us is indep and
postponement on house B 1377 this a
roller call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
before I announce the vote I want to
make it clear the house will be in order
and that includes the gallery no
clapping no screaming no hollering from
anybody if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 212 voting yay 168 voting nay death
and postponement
passes like to make a
motion
that
the for what reason does a member
rise the house will be in order Mr
Speaker I would like to move that the
debate on House Bill 1377 be printed in
the permanent journal without
objection
Mr Speaker hold on hold
on the committee on labor industrial
real dat services to which was referred
House Bill 1522 FN relative to weekly
benefit amounts for unemployment
compensation the chair recognizes
representative
Sullivan
chair recognize representative Sullivan
for a
motion thank you Mr
Speaker if I
know that this what what's your motion
representative thank you I I move to
table I I move to table
1522 sayable
members
recognized to to speak to
to
Pi do he's going to do the
pi represent INF for CH recognizes
representative infantine for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that I agree with my good friend from
Grantham and if I know there's a uh uh
another bill coming over from the Senate
I would uh ask you to agree with my
friend from Grantham and vote uh the
tabling
motion the mo the motion before us is
table House Bill 1522 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
1522 is laid on the
table for what reason does a member rise
just make a Motion state your motion I
would like to move to remove House Bill
232 from the
table n debatable
motion
reest a division has been requested
members take your
seats
e
the mo the motion house will be in order
the motion before us is to remove from
the table House
Bill
232 this is a going to be division
vote chair recognizes representative
Sullivan for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that house
bill 232 deals with public sector worker
safety
and if I know the public sector worker
safety is an important matter that
deserves a debate and a
vote and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that folks that oppose Right to Work
support worker safety would I now press
the green button to remove House Bill
232 from the table thank
you Jo recognize represent of infantine
for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know there were two
amendments to this initial bill one
which had a th
page um document that was going to be
have to be uh adhered to by the
department of Mr Speaker if I know that
the other amendment of that I had was
going to allow them to do it them the
Department of Labor to do it themselves
and Mr Speaker if I further know that I
spoke with the Department of Labor
Commissioner earlier this week and they
heard what the legislature said and
they're making plans themselves to
update the safety manual the Department
of Labor utilizes for public
employees would I vote no to this
motion motion before us is to move House
Bill two 232 from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
for
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 182 voting aay 186 voting a the
motion
fails
Committee on Public Works and highways
to which was referred House Bill 11 1468
FNA an act directing the Department of
Transportation to develop a Conway
Branch rail line master plan consider
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Mark mccon for the
committee the amendment is
0530 printed in house record 7 page 50 6
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay no the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is on to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I close nay the
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted and represent of leechman
declared a conflict of interest and did
not to participate and it is going to
finance
jury the committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 1423 FN an act
requiring the commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to identify all old growth
mature forests on public land in the
state of New Hampshire having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Sen of Tanya
Tanya DY for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that bill ought to pass
representative Rosemary rung for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does the member rise for a motion
State your motion uh indefinitely
postpone the motion is in order the
motion before us is indefinitely
postponed 14 speak
1423 chair recognizes representative
Kaplan thank you Mr Speaker and uh thank
you
colleagues I Rise Against The indefinite
postponement motion on hp1 1423
requiring the commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to identify all old growth and
mature forests on public land in the
state of New Hampshire in 1996 this
legislature enacted RSA 227 declaring
that the public welfare of the state is
served by The Prudent acquisition and
management of reservations to provide
Forest benefits and for the purpose of
demonstrating sound forestry principles
protecting habitat for plants animals
and other organisms conserving forested
watersheds preserving areas of rare and
exemplary natural beauty and ecological
value and providing for Perpetual Public
Access and
use this bill aims to add to that
tradition of stewardship for the people
of our state by adding two categories to
four lands that provide so many of our
essential ecosystem Services old growth
and mature forests represent our most
valued forestry assets a value that's
increasingly recognized and monetized on
private lands but that should also be
recognized and valued by us the rightful
owners of the public Forest
lands hb1 1423 merily would require the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to carry out an inventory that
is being conducted by all of our our
neighboring states to identify and map
old growth and mature forests in the
interest of expanding those essential
ecosystem
Services carbon storage flood and
drought mitigation water quality and
biodiversity
protection the original Bill required
this work to be carried out on all
public land in the state on the
assumption that the White Mountain
National Forest currently surveyed by
the US Forest Service would not have to
be surveyed by our forest
division given the likely collaboration
and cooperation of the branches of our
federal and state agencies when it
became apparent that our state forestry
division would be required to carry out
the work on the national forest or at
least that's how the legislation was
being
interpreted I drafted an amendment it's
in your uh seat Pockets that uh
unfortunately was not considered by the
committee this amendment would reduce
the
scope of the uh of the assignment from
over
a million Acres of public land to a
little over 200,000 Acres of State
managed park lands this reduction in
scope will reduce the need for
additional staff from 7 to two we heard
from the Department in the public
hearing old growth forests are receiving
scrutiny as we seek to fight the threat
of climate
change it's a given now that in terms of
fighting climate change not only are we
going to have
to uh give up our addiction to fossil
fuels but we're also going to have to
draw down a sign significant portion of
the carbon currently in the atmosphere
due to human
activities this need to take carbon back
out of the atmosphere is leading to a
rethink of the best and most valued use
of our forest lands New Hampshire is
uniquely blessed as we know with
abundant Forest cover and that's why we
have the opportunity to play a crucial
role in avoiding the worst outcomes of a
changing
climate one of our greatest natural
tools for fighting climate crisis has
been right in front of us all along our
forests
and the best trees in the forest for
carbon
storage biodiversity and enhanced water
quality are the big old
trees every year forests in the United
States absorb 133% of our carbon
emissions and if we let them continue to
grow they could do so much more that's
what this bill is intended to do on
behalf of the people the owners of the
resource to identify old growth and
mature forests on public lands that have
the potential to be most useful and to
map them so that we know what we have
and how best to manage what is ours and
ours
alone so please vote r on this
indefinite postponement so that we can
consider the amendment and the
underlying Bill and move to protect and
identify all growth and mature force on
our state Parklands thank
you chair recognize representative
Donley thank you Mr Speaker speak Mr
Speaker we broadly opposed this
particular Amendment and also the things
that we're looking for mainly because we
heard from the New Hampshire forestry
and Timber organizations New Hampshire's
largest environmental organizations and
the state-owned forestry departments New
Hampshire division of forest and lands
New Hampshire Timber Owners Association
and the Society of the protection of New
Hampshire forest all oppos this you want
to know why because we already do this
so under the authority of the NH native
plant protection act of RSA
217a our division natural heritage
Bureau identifies facilities protect
faculties that protect the state rare
plants exemplary natural communities
types of forest Wetlands gr grasslands
Etc
including what may be described as old
growth a mature forest in addition
inventorying Mappy old growth will take
a lot of time staff and resources more
than what's been depicted on that fiscal
note so please understand that there's
no scientific basis for the universal
definition of mature or old growth
because some of our forests have slow
growth happening in Old growth New
Hampshire forests so this bill we need
to look at it and go would believe
there's bigger and more important Forest
management challenges such as exotic
bugs for uh Forest lost to development
invasive diseases fire and facing the
New Hampshire State Forest then
inventory and mapping growth as a
separate project this is already an
existing project thank
you the motion before us is a definite
postponement on
House Bill
1423 representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
represent
yes
yeah
St
e
members be in your
seats the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on House Bill
1423 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognize representative rung
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
speaker colleagues if I know that our
forests are among New Hampshire's most
precious resources and if I know that
collecting data on the maturity and
extent of old growth forests will inform
our ability to mitigate floods droughts
and preserve important habitats and if I
want New Hampshire to join our
neighboring states and the US Forest
Service in inv inventorying State Forest
would I now press the red button so that
the underlying Bill and its Amendment
which addresses concerns raised in the
bill can be discussed thank
you chair recogniz representative Rulo
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I
know that the New Hampshire Timberland
owners ass Association came out against
this bill plus the director of the New
Hampshire division of forest and land
stated and I quote our agency
already already has a process in place
to identify such rare natural
communities on state land and thereby
meeting the state's obligation expressed
in this bill
unquote
and if I know the price TX tag of this
bill as
submitted was
$2,240 th000 over a threeyear
period and finally if I know that this
bill was ited on a 15 to5 majority vote
and failed a committee Rec uh Rec
reconsideration on a on a majority
repeat now majority not a to
vote but a majority vote on the
reconsideration then would I punch that
green button and maybe we can get out of
here a little bit earlier thank you the
motion before us is the indefinite
postponement of House Bill 1423 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
you
representan
all members president at opportunity to
vote house T stay the
vote 228 voting nay 141 voting
nay House Bill 1423 is indefinitely
postponed majority of the committee on
resource Recreation and development to
which was referred House Bill 1709 FN an
act establishing a tax on land used for
carbon credits considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation of the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Iman
Kelly for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation the bill be referred
to interim study sen of T Tim the for
the minority of the committee the
amendment is 0686 H printed in house
record 7 page
9293 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is a to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
Ways and
Means
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 1465 FN the how the
house will be in order we're getting
close to being
done an act relative to studies of
nuclear energy Technologies having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation to Bill a to pass to the
amendment s of Doug Thomas for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Wendy Thomas for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
065 printed in house record 7 Pages 53-
55 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended the chair
recognizes representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr
Speaker I come before you today to
oppose House Bill
1645 relative to studies of nuclear
energy
Technologies which is in my most humble
opinion a hot
mess what does it do
first of all it renames an existing
Department in the department of energy
to change it from the office of offshore
wind industry development to the office
of energy
Innovation to better reflect new
energies as well as to pave the way for
nuclear power in New
Hampshire this bill then goes on to
establish a position of coordinators of
nuclear development and Regulatory
activity and assigns duties but just
what those Duties are is anyone's guess
nuclear is
relegate you're not going to do okay
nuclear is regulated by the federal
nuclear regulator Regulatory Commission
the NRC which oversees the sighting and
installation of any new nuclear energy
facilities it is as clear as mud how the
New Hampshire Department of energy would
interact with the
NRC and who would own what roles in any
kind of
process New Hampshire already has a
nuclear facility and supposedly it is
already being overseen by the staff at
the department of energy so why the need
for an entire office to oversee a
process that wouldn't be needed for
several years let's talk about funding
this Bill if passed wouldn't be
effective until
2025 which is why there is the claim
that there is no funding for this bill
however this little backdoor bill would
require eventual funding and Personnel
hiring in order to staff the new office
with people who have nuclear
experience someone will need to fund
those positions starting in
2025 the New Hampshire Department of
energy gave testimony that they would
need additional staff to cover the new
roles outlined in this bill workers come
with a cost and nuclear experts do not
come
cheap and let us not forget that we have
been warned by the house finance
committee that any bills with fiscal
notes will not continue this calendar
year and that we should expect to be
quote disappointed at the outcome of any
such
Bill during committee discussion we
heard that this bill would essentially
be putting a sign out for all businesses
to see that says New Hampshire welcomes
nuclear come on
down but with the permits and planning
that needs to be done for any nuclear
facility New Hampshire is a good 10
years that's 10 years away from any
nuclear power plant a
decade are we really going to create an
office of nuclear oversight that will be
paid to sit for 10 years before anything
happens yet another problem with this
bill is that it calls for participation
of the Public Utilities Commission on on
any nuclear energy projects which is
just not in their purview they don't do
that the pu's mission is to Ure that
customers of regulated utilities receive
safe adequate and reliable service
service at just and reasonable
costs lastly we already have an energy
sighting of an energy facility sighting
process in New Hampshire and it is
unclear what if anything else is needed
for any new nuclear
business House Bill 1645 is a bill that
requires significant study revision and
work before ever being passed by the
Full House I urge you to oppose the
current motion of
OTP and instead please kill this bill so
that we can go home thank you does a
member yield the
questions no member does not yield chair
recognize representative
Ammon thank you Mr
Speaker
I'm going to clear up some uh
misconceptions from the the
prev thank you Mr
Speaker I'm going to clear up some
misconceptions uh of the previous
speaker um the the claim that this bill
requires further
study this bill is uh a product of a
study commission that this body created
two years ago and that ran the entire
entirety of last year to
2023 and on that commission we had the
chair of the Pu the general Council of
the Department of energy uh a
representative from the Bureau of
Economic Development uh energy experts
we brought in federal experts industry
experts manufacturers of advanced
nuclear you can read our 50-page report
if you go to nuclear n. energy and this
bill is in one of the recommendations on
that report so I'll get into what this
bill does
does in our research we looked at uh RSA
162b which is our atomic energy statutes
this bill updates those statutes and it
does three
things it updates some of the the
obsolete terms that are in that statute
for instance the NRC is not in the
statute with this bill the the old the
old term will be updated to
NRC it puts it ties our statutes to the
federal definition
of advanced nuclear this is one of the
recommendations we heard on the
commission so the definition of advanced
nuclear will be in our statutes and the
third thing it does there's an obsolete
position that's been in our statutes for
decades it's been ignored for at least a
decade that there's a coordinator of
atomic energy uh
studies so every two years this
coordinator was supposed to work with
various state agencies deliver a report
on the atomic energy industry to the
governor and the general counsel that's
current statute and it's been ignored so
what this bill does is it proposes to
resurrect that position put it under the
the newly the since created Department
of energy to make it one of their
responsibilities and so it's a refresh
of current statute and the idea is that
our state government would pay attention
to the progress of advanced nuclear
which could should be coming to
commercialization the next 5 to 10 years
so it continues this the study process
the department of energy was involved
with an amendment on this bill uh of
course they take no position but they
they are aware of the amendment and had
been working on it in the wisdom of the
committee uh the committee amendment
that we just passed would expand the
role of the office of offshore wind
development to expand it to include all
energy Innovation so not just just wind
but also Advanced nuclear solar battery
storage hydrogen there's many things
that could help our economy improve our
electric rates we heard earlier today
that we have the highest electric rates
in the country so I I think this is a
this is planting a seed this bill and uh
I urge you to pass it um let me just
give you uh a couple of stats there are
over 40 companies working in the
advanced nuclear sector and including a
company called Terra power that's owned
by Bill Gates out of Wyoming but many
other
companies our state can position itself
to be in the supply chain for advanced
nuclear the workforce for advanced
nuclear and and the development of
companies themselves in Newington New
Hampshire if you represent Newington we
have Westinghouse manufacturing plant
they manufacture components of nuclear
power plants and right here in
Manchester we have a startup for an
advanced nuclear company called star
cube that you may not be aware of but
now now you might look into it so I urge
you to to pass this bill it it puts the
focus of our state government on
Advanced nuclear but also all energy
Innovations so please support House Bill
1465 thank you does the member yield the
questions I do the member yield
represent will you may inquire thank
you are you aware that although this
winter has been relative ly mild the CEO
of eversource last year wrote to the
president and said and I quote New
England will not have sufficient natural
gas to meet power supply needs for the
region in the event of a severe spell
cold this winter that as we continue to
put greater and greater demands on our
electric grid we need to start looking
for Solutions and the bill before us is
one of those possible
solutions I do believe that and I'd also
like to mention that the bill doesn't
spend money in its current form so uh I
forgot to add that in my speech thank
you the motion before us is aut to pass
as amended on House Bill
1465 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I oppose
nay the motion passes committ report is
adopted and it it's on its way to
finings I'd ask that members continue to
come in and take your seats we have a
division coming up in a couple of
minutes now there's no debate there's no
debate so once I get done reading this
we will be having a a division vote
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
1697 FN an act suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
reduction credit programs for a period
of two years considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Douglas
Thomas for the committee the amendment
is
0482 H printed in house record 7 page 92
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay you guys have it and
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with Amendment this is going to be
a division vote so members take your
seats
e
the motion before is a to pass with
Amendment on H Bill 16 9 7 chair
recognizes representative Noel for a
parliamentary inquiry how will be in
order thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that the long-term
accumulation of carbon in the Trees of
our forests referred to as carbon
sequestration has become a new source of
revenue for land owners and
investors and if I also know that New
Hampshire has no registry in in which to
record the Acres of forest land which
are managed for carbon credits or carbon
offsets to be sold into existing carbon
markets and if I further know that
Timber tax revenue is reduced for the
abing towns because the amount of Timber
harvested off of land that is managed
for carbon sequestration is greatly
reduced then would I now press the green
button so that a study of the issues
related to Lost Timber tax revenues can
be authorized and performed thank
you the motion before us is a to pass as
with Amendment on H Bill
1697 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
mes
representative Ames I need a thumbs up
or thumbs down representative
Herbert representative
Herbert I need a thumbs up or a thumbs
down thank you not
fer representative
fitting
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote 356 voting aay 10 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
committee on this the committee on the
special committee on child care to which
was referred House Bill 1611 FN an act
relative to establishing a child care
Workforce fund having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation the bill ought
to pass with Amendment pres Rebecca
McWilliams for the committee the
amendment is 0562 H printed in house
record 7 page 66 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question
all a division has who requested a
division representative Spain is
requested a division members take your
seats
moot the motion before us is house house
will be in order the motion before it
says Auto pass as amended on House Bill
1611 this is a Vision vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to say to the
vote 195 voting a 69 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's going to Ways
and Means representative Barry declared
a conflict and did not
participate froment isve to
table we're on now the last bill that
was moved from consent calendar
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
1644 FN act requiring the department of
energy to initiate an investigation the
benefits and key considerations
regarding support for clean or
non-carbon emitting power generation
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment so Michael votes for the
committee chair recognize representative
votes thank you Mr Speaker I move to
table House Bill
1644 the Move Motion is to table House
Bill
1644 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I
I suppose
they the eyes have it and House Bill
1644 is laid on the
table recognize before I do this before
I recognize the member I just want to
thank all the members today we
anticipated on being a lot later than we
are I think you all did yman work to get
us out of here on
[Applause]
time
the chair recognizes representative or
Osborne for the third reading motion
thank you resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered to third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet at the call of the
chair the question is on the third
reading motion are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I
n the eyes he and the motion is adopted
we have an announcement in one unanimous
cons please be mind the chair the chair
recognizes the clerk for an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker as you are exiting
we do have one unanimous consent uh I I
would ask that you please give attention
to the member when they're delivering it
also if you are leaving please empty out
your seat Pockets uh especially as uh
many of you have had snacks thank
you
chair recognized representative wher for
unanimous
consent will beend the the house will be
attentive to the
member thank you Mr Speaker I know it's
late so anyone who has to go home I
completely understand today is the last
day in February that we will be meeting
in house session February is also Black
History Month and this will Mark the end
of Black History
Month I uh I grew up white in this state
to put it plainly I grew up to a single
mother in the manad region who had a
didn't have a lot of melon in her skin
and I didn't uh meet my first black
person until I was about maybe five or
six years old I didn't understand black
history I didn't know the importance of
it and sometimes when I was I found
myself as a teenager and I'd hear it's
Black History Month it's Black History
Month well why do we need a Black
History Month I'd say to
myself but in being here in the
legislature it was not truly until last
year when I met representative Linda
Harriet
goth uh that I truly understood the
importance of this month that I
understood what being black was
especially here in this legislature when
I can look out and see representative D
Lorenzo and representative Judy when I
get to meet representative Harvey key
these people who blazed a trail to allow
a young idealistic kid from petero with
dreadlocks to serve in the legislature I
mean that is the importance of Black
History Month that's the importance of
celebrating the history of a people
black history month was originated by a
man named Carter J
Woodson and he originated it as
something called negro history
week he created that week to highlight
the contributions black people have made
to our all of us the American story and
he had hoped that so-called Black
History Month eventually would no longer
be necessary as the two would become
indistinguishable as black history would
become American history as American
history would become black history as we
wouldn't think of it as anything other
than American
history and we stand here
today honoring him in his in his vision
because New Hampshire is deeply
intertwined with black history our
cities and towns abolish slavery as
early as
1805 that was Portsmith that's right
that's
right our Inseparable history with
abolition with black history ranges from
as macro as our churches being among the
first to call for abolition sparking a
movement of change in this country that
would end Catt slavery as we know it and
free so many people in this country From
Slavery to as micro as Oda let me get
her name right let me get her name right
as Oda a slave of George Washington's
who escaped here to Smith and her house
still stands there today if you get a
chance I definitely recommend going to
check it out and she stood here and
lived a peaceful life here in New
Hampshire as the president sent his
goons out to try and find her black
history history of a people history of
abolition runs so deep in this state
and I cannot do the history of our state
and its connection to civil rights and
the abolition movements here on the
floor any justice
but what I can do is honor those members
as I began to do here in the beginning
of my speech who came before me who
allowed me to stand here today before
you as a representative of Peter bro New
Hampshire those members being The
Honorable Henry Boyd Richardson of Keem
1975 to 1977 the first African American
to serve in this
legislature that's
right
The Honorable Lionel Johnson of
Manchester who served from 1989 to
2003 The Honorable Linda long of nsha
who served from 1987 to 1989 being the
first female African-American
legislator The Honorable Juani tabell
who served from nsha from 1989 to
1993 y
The Honorable Harvey key who served from
Nashville from 1999 to
2001 The Honorable Jackie Witherspoon
who served from Nashua from exiter
excuse me 1997 to
1999 The Honorable Chris Roberts from
Kean from 2007 2005 to 20
5 the honorable James Lawrence of Hudson
who served from 2006 to
2008 The Honorable Melanie Lake who
served from 2006 to 2010 and went on to
go serve on that other side of the wall
over there but we don't talk about that
right
Mr The Honorable Carol ests who served
from Plymouth 2006 to
2008 The Honorable Clare Clark who
served from bosin 2002 to
2010 The Honorable caroleta Alia who
served from 2012 to 2018 and then again
from 2020 to
2022 and now the good ones no I'm just
kidding I'm
sorry Harvey will give me Harvey
give me crap for that um folks
representative Jean Judy of
Manchester 2005 to right
now representative Damon Ford freshman
from
Manchester my good friend my caucus
leader representative Linda Harry goth
from
naswa and then representative Charlotte
D Lorenzo serving on the Judiciary
Committee from New
Market folks what else can I say these
these these members have oh yeah and me
Jonah wheeler from Peter bro that's
right I didn't think I could vote for
myself folks so much has happened in
this body so much hate
but also love so much has been brought
together and the fact that we have come
so far I mean within some of our
lifetimes you would not have seen what
we just saw the fact that all of us can
be so respectful to one another I mean
there's some moments we all have our
moments but all of us in general can be
respectful to one another that is a
beautiful thing it's the United States
of America it's the fact that we can
have different cultures being standing
strong in their culture honoring their
culture and living together that's a
country that we've never seen before and
it's something that we cannot let go so
easily so thank you very much for
allowing me to serve I'm a proud
American I'm a proud member of this body
and I thank you for allowing me to speak
today let's go
[Music]
home the marks will be printed without
objection
representative hosman moves at the house
stand in recess for a purpose of
introduction of bills and roll build
amendments and roll Bill reports vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppos nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted the
house is in recess to the call of the
chair